I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello everybody. Hello. Are you in your comfy pants? Do you have on a t-shirt and maybe some flip-flops? Why are you saying these things? You can see me. I'm talking to you guys out there. Oh, because it's casual Friday. Because it's casual Friday. Oh
我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了《办公室》重温播客《终极办公室》。每周我们将剖析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士们。大家好。你好。你穿着舒服的裤子吗？你穿着T恤也许还有人字拖吗？你为什么说这些？你能看到我。我在跟你们大家说话。哦，因为今天是便服星期五。因为今天是便服星期五。哦
yeah. Why didn't I dress more casually today? I don't know. You look real spiffy. Well, I know why. Because we have a special guest. We do. Let's start by saying that Casual Friday is season 5 episode 26. Sang. It was written by Anthony Farrell and directed by Brent Forrester. Little tidbit. What is it? Editor was Claire Scanlon. And our DP was Matt Stone. Hey, I like this team. I do too. And it was the first time this team had worked together on an episode. Wow. Yeah. They did a good job. They did. Here's your summary. It is casual Friday at Dunder Mifflin. Finally. It has been reinstated. Michael is back. He's the
对啊。为什么我今天没有穿得更休闲一点？我不知道。你看起来真的很时髦。嗯，我知道为什么。因为我们有特别嘉宾。没错。让我们先说一下，便服星期五是第五季第二十六集。对。它由安东尼·法雷尔编剧，布伦特·福雷斯特导演。一个小花絮。是什么？剪辑师是克莱尔·斯坎伦。我们的摄影指导是马特·斯通。嘿，我喜欢这个团队。我也喜欢。这是这个团队第一次合作一集节目。哇。是的。他们干得很好。确实如此。这是你的剧情梗概。邓德米夫林迎来了便服星期五。终于。它又恢复了。迈克尔回来了。他是
manager. It's casual Friday again. But some of the employees are taking a few too many liberties with their outfit choices. Like Angel is not happy. Angel doesn't need to see a grown man's feet. Probably ever. I'm surprised that we didn't see bare feet on Kevin as well. Well, yeah. But here's the thing. The sales team is resentful that Pam and Ryan came on as new salespeople and that they get to keep the clients that they stole from everybody else while they were working at Michael Scott Paper Company. I mean, that's just awkward. Yeah. So there's a bit of a rivalry that's gonna happen on this episode today. Mm-hmm.
经理。又到了便服星期五。但一些员工在他们的服装选择上有点太放肆了。比如安吉拉很不高兴。安吉拉可不想看到一个成年男人的脚。可能永远都不想。我很惊讶我们没有在凯文脚上也看到光脚。好吧，是的。但问题是。销售团队对帕姆和瑞安作为新销售人员加入感到不满，而且他们还能保留在迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司工作时从其他人那里抢来的客户。我的意思是，这就很尴尬。是的。所以今天这一集里会有一些竞争。嗯。
But first, there's a pretty big thing that kicks off this episode. This is an epic cold open. It's the chili spill cold open. Oh my gosh. Kevin's recipe, the pride he takes in it. He tries to make it up the stairs. He does. And what happens? Oh boy. Oh boy. Well, we felt like this was the perfect opportunity to speak to the man behind the chili, Brian Baumgartner. That's right. Brian is our fast fact one, two, and three today. Yes. We can't wait to talk to him. All right. Here he is. Brian Baumgartner. Hello. What is happening? I'm so happy to be with you guys. Why don't you buddy, you have a plant. I love that you have a plant. I was
但首先，有一个相当重大的事情拉开了这一集的序幕。这是一个史诗级的冷开场。这是洒辣椒酱的冷开场。哦天哪。凯文的食谱，他为此感到骄傲。他试图走上楼梯。他确实做到了。然后发生了什么？哦天哪。哦天哪。好吧，我们觉得这是与辣椒背后的男人布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳对话的绝佳机会。没错。布赖恩就是我们今天的第一、第二和第三个趣味事实。是的。我们迫不及待地想跟他聊聊。好的。他来了。布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳。你好。发生什么事了？我很高兴能和你们在一起。你怎么，伙计，你有一盆植物。我喜欢你有一盆植物。我被
told that brings humanity and warmth. Oh, what is the award that's over your shoulder? You know what? No one has ever asked that in all of the Zooms I've been doing for a year and a half. Truly, it always made me laugh. I don't have my college diploma, but I'll read. I have Penn Foster College, a certificate of completion, which I always thought was a good joke for Kevin Malone in a county. That is awesome. A certificate of completion. Maybe all diplomas say that, but I thought, oh, it's they're they're doing a little funny joke. Like it's not really a degree in accounting. He took a weekend course. He has a piece of paper
告知这能带来人性和温暖。哦，你肩膀上的那个奖项是什么？你知道吗？在我一年半以来做的所有Zoom访谈中，从来没有人问过这个。真的，这总是让我笑。我没有大学文凭，但我会读。我有宾福斯特学院的结业证书，我一直认为这对会计师凯文·马龙来说是个不错的笑话。太棒了。结业证书。也许所有文凭都这么写，但我想，哦，他们在开一个小玩笑。就像它不是真正的会计学位一样。他上了一个周末课程。他有一张参与证明
for participating. Well, listen, we are here to talk about the office with you and obviously about this amazing cold open. But Brian, we always ask our guests, how did you get your job on the office? I was walking down Hollywood Boulevard. No. Oh, I like the start of that. No, I feel like my story is always seems like a humble brag or something. But my truth is I I moved to Los Angeles and I considered it my job to just watch television. And so I started watching television shows because I was like, well, if I get an audition on this show, don't I need to know what's the style? What's the form? How are how do the
。好吧，听着，我们是来和你谈论《办公室》以及显然还有这个令人惊叹的冷开场的。但是布赖恩，我们总是问我们的嘉宾，你是怎么得到《办公室》的工作的？我当时正在好莱坞大道上散步。不。哦，我喜欢这个开头的说法。不，我觉得我的故事总是听起来像是在低调地炫耀什么的。但我的真相是我搬到了洛杉矶，我把看电视当作我的工作。所以我开始看电视节目，因为我想，如果我在这个节目中得到试镜，难道我不应该知道风格是什么？形式是什么？角色通常是如何
characters generally behave? So I started watching television and I watched this show called The Office, the British version of The Office. And I started working with a manager and I called him and I said, if there is a show that is that is going to be on television because they announced they were doing a pilot, I was like, this is the show for me. And I had an agent at the time and the agent who I called and said the same thing to said, well, they're looking for unknown people, but not like you unknown, not like totally unknown. But my manager called and called and called Alson Jones and I went in and I met with Phyllis
表现的？所以我开始看电视，我看了这个叫《办公室》的节目，也就是英国版的《办公室》。我开始和一个经纪人合作，我打电话给他说，如果有这样一个节目将在电视上播出，因为他们宣布他们正在做一个试播集，我就想，这就是适合我的节目。我当时有一个经纪人，我打电话给他说同样话的那个经纪人说，好吧，他们在找默默无闻的人，但不是像你那样默默无闻，不是完全默默无闻那种。但我的经理给爱尔森·琼斯打了又打、打了又打，然后我去了，我见到了菲利斯
and I read and then she passed me on to Alson Jones and I read with her and I got an appointment for the role of Stanley and I knew that was not the part for me. I knew that the part for me was in the British version, his name was Keith and I was like that I get that comedy. So I went in to this big call and I read the role of Stanley as though I were Kevin. Oh, wow. So smart, Brian. Well, or it could have been like, what is this? But right, so I went, I was there at the same time Oscar Nunez was there and Leslie David Baker were there. I can't remember who else, but I know that they were there and so I did it. They said,
并试读了，然后她把我转给爱尔森·琼斯，我和她一起试读，我得到了斯坦利这个角色的面试机会，我知道那不是适合我的角色。我知道适合我的角色在英国版里，他的名字叫基斯，我想我懂那种喜剧。所以我走进了这个大型面试，我以凯文的方式朗读了斯坦利的角色。哦，哇。太聪明了，布赖恩。嗯，或者它也可能是，这是什么？但是对，所以我去了，奥斯卡·努涅斯和莱斯利·大卫·贝克也在那里。我不记得还有谁了，但我知道他们当时也在那儿，所以我读了。他们说，
thank you and I left and thought, well, that was a failed experiment and Alson Jones ran down the hall. She said, hey, you know, they actually want to look at this other character and I in my head, I went big go and went in, read that and and that's that's how it happened. But you never said, Alson, I think I'd be a better fit for Kevin. Would you give me a shot at it? You just took this risk of reading Stanley like Kevin. Yes, because, oh, because again, I was totally unknown, right? Yeah. I didn't have, I didn't have the experience, I mean now, of course, that's what I would do. But yeah, no, I didn't. I didn't, I was, you know,
谢谢，然后我离开了，心想，好吧，那是一个失败的实验，爱尔森·琼斯顺着走廊跑过来。她说，嘿，你知道吗，他们其实想看看这个别的角色，然后在我的脑海里，我心想，太棒了，走进去，读了那个角色，然后，事情就是这样发生的。但你从来没有对爱尔森说，我觉得我更适合演凯文。你能给我个机会吗？你只是冒着像凯文那样读斯坦利台词的风险。是的，因为，哦，因为同样地，我完全默默无闻，对吧？是的。我没有，我没有经验，我的意思是现在，当然，那是我会做的。但是，是的，不，我没有。我，你知道，
happy to have an opportunity. You know, I had just moved to Los Angeles a few months before that. Yeah, I knew that. I knew that because the first day on set when we got to know each other just briefly chatting, Oscar and I were sort of commiserating about how many years we'd been out here plugging away and we're like, what about you, Brian? And he was like, I've lived here like eight weeks. We're like, what? I've been here two months. We're like, holy crap. Well, the thing is like standing out to me are the number of people who came in for a role other than the one they wound up in. Angela, you first came in for Pam, but
很高兴能有机会。你知道，我几个月前才搬到洛杉矶。是的，我知道。我知道是因为在片场的第一天，当我们通过简短的交谈互相了解时，奥斯卡和我在发牢骚，抱怨我们在这里摸爬滚打了多少年，我们说，布赖恩，你呢？他说，我在这里住了大约八 weeks。我们说，什么？我在这里两个月了。我们说，天哪。好吧，让我印象深刻的是那些来面试最终出演角色之外的人数。安吉拉，你最初是来试镜帕姆的，但
then also Ed originally auditioned for Michael Scott. John was brought in to play Dwight. Yeah. And Rain auditioned for Michael Scott as well. I know, that's crazy. A lot of people. Yeah. I feel like on the set, you and John Krasinski were pretty good buds. Yeah, you guys became good pals. And the four of us, I would say you and John, me and Angela, we could often be found in John Krasinski's trailer during lunchtime. You guys had some heated Madden football matches. I mean, for years. Now I hear people talking about, you know, what a family we were and the and the crew and the cast and all of that, by the way, is true. But
后来埃德最初也为迈克尔·斯科特试镜。约翰被带来扮演德怀特。是的。雷恩也为迈克尔·斯科特试镜了。我知道，这太疯狂了。很多人。是的。我觉得在片场，你和约翰·卡拉辛斯基是非常好的朋友。是的，你们成了好哥们。我们四个人，可以说你和约翰，我和安吉拉，经常可以在午餐时间在约翰·卡拉辛斯基的房车里找到。你们有一些激烈的麦登橄榄球比赛。我是说，持续了多年。现在我听到人们谈论，你知道，我们是一个多么温馨的大家庭，剧组和演员等等，顺便说一下，这些都是真的。但
then undoubtedly someone will mention like lunch. And at lunch, you know, you would sit with this birth. I didn't sit with anyone. John Krasinski and I played Madden football in his trailer. Essentially every single. That's right. It was weird. We could hear you guys. If we walked past the trailer at lunch, you could literally hear like, Oh, come on. Sometimes you would let rain play. Mm hmm. But it seemed like grudgingly. You'd be like, Oh, I guess we have to let someone else play. But it was the two of you. And I would like to know, are you willing to go on record and say who was better? Because I have a
毫无疑问，有人会提到午餐。而在午餐时，你知道，你会和这个人坐在一起。我没有和任何人坐在一起。约翰·卡拉辛斯基和我在他的房车里玩麦登橄榄球。基本上每一个。没错。这很奇怪。我们能听到你们的声音。如果我们午餐时走过房车，你 literalmente 可以听到，哦，拜托。有时你会让雷恩玩。嗯哼。但看起来很不情愿。你会说，哦，我想我们得让别人玩了。但其实是你们两个。我想知道，你愿意公开表态说谁更厉害吗？因为我有一个
memory of who was better. Who do you think was better? Mm hmm. I on it. Well, if I say that we were even, that sounds like I'm hedging. But I do, we kind of, we both had teams that if we were allowed on that day to play those teams, the other person couldn't beat us. Mine weird. I wasn't a fan was the Chargers. And so this is so great. They called it the Gates play. Listen, if you ever play old Madden and Antonio Gates in the scene, it's a touchdown every time. So yeah, there's a pro tip for you old Madden players. Yeah. That's what I would say. He would get mad when he lost. I will say he would get way
关于谁更厉害的记忆。你觉得谁更厉害？嗯哼。我。好吧，如果我说我们不相上下，这听起来像我在留退路。但我确实，我们俩都有这样的球队，如果那天允许我们用那些球队玩，另一个人就打败不了我。我的奇怪。我不是粉丝，是闪电队。所以这太棒了。他们称之为盖茨战术。听着，如果你在老版麦登里用安东尼·盖茨，每次都是达阵。所以，给你们这些老麦登玩家的一个专业提示。是的。这就是我要说的。他输了的时候会生气。我要说他会变得比我
more mad than I. Oh yeah. And then grumpy. Grumpy. Because I was gonna say, Brian, I think you were the better player. My memory from the lunches where I watched you guys play was you winning. And then John getting pissed. That's your that's what you held on to. Well, I remember you guys doing the Dunder Mifflin Fantasy Football League, which is still going strong. I have been told this week's standings are that this week's standings are that John is in fourth, Rain is in fifth and Brian, you are in ninth. So here's the thing. I played Rain this week. And by the way, when you all hear this, it'll be that
生气得多。哦，是的。然后变得暴躁。暴躁。因为我想说，布赖恩，我觉得你是更好的玩家。我从看你们比赛的午餐时间里得到的记忆是你赢了。然后约翰气急败坏。那是你记住的。好吧，我记得你们搞了邓德米夫林梦幻橄榄球联盟，现在依然办得很好。我被告知本周的排名是，本周的排名是约翰排第四，雷恩排第五，而布赖恩，你排第九。所以事情是这样的。我这周和雷恩对阵了。顺便说一句，当你们听到这个时，
stands will be different. Spoiler alert. I lost to Rain this week by a point. And it flipped everything. So yeah, I'm I'm in I'm in trouble. But I I think I'm four and four. Rain is I think five and three. So like it literally flipped everything. I was going through our fan mail, Brian, and a frequently asked question was about your voice, because you very much do not sound like Kevin in real life. And people were curious, how did you develop this voice for the character of Kevin? Well, look, I okay, so going back. And my manager and I who I'm still with
排名会有所不同。剧透警告。我这周以一分之差输给了雷恩。这把一切都颠倒了。所以，是的，我，我有麻烦了。但我，我想我是四胜四负。雷恩我想是五胜三负。所以，这真的是把一切都颠倒了。布赖恩，我一直在浏览我们的粉丝邮件，一个常见的问题是关于你的声音听起来一点也不像现实生活中的凯文，人们很好奇你是如何为凯文这个角色开发出这个声音的？好吧，听着，我，好吧，所以回到过去。我和我的经理，我至今仍然
now all these years later, we still have this joke. So the casting notice about Kevin was the following. And I know it's true because I've said it so many times. The only thing remarkable about Kevin is that he is remarkably unremarkable. And so our joke is always like my manager saying to Alison Jones and everyone, you've got to meet this guy. He is so unremarkable. He is just the most unremarkable. So that's really where it started, which again, really came from the character of Keith in the British version. I was like a theater actor, right? Like for me, the construction of character,
和他在合作，这些年过去了，我们仍然有这个笑话。关于凯文的选角通知是这样的。我知道这是真的，因为我已经说过很多次了。关于凯文唯一非凡的地方就是他极其平庸。所以我们的笑话总是像我的经理对爱尔森·琼斯和每个人说的那样，你必须见见这家伙。他是如此平庸。他简直是最平庸的。所以这真的是它的起源，这再次真正来自于英国版里的基斯这个角色。我是一个戏剧演员，对吧？就像对我来说，角色的构建，
that's what I feel like I did, right? So I wasn't really an improv guy. It was for me about about the character. And so for me, it's not like putting on a voice. But it's really about the body, the way the body moves. I know this is what many people are turning off. Right now, you should see. I'm on the edge of my seat. You are speaking to her theater nerd heart. Yes, I'm hearing you. You're bought you created your character in your body and that body in my body informed your voice. So it came from the whole body. It didn't start just in your throat. Correct. And the way and the way of
这正是我觉得我所做的事情，对吧？所以我真的不是一个即兴演员。对我来说，关键在于角色。所以对我来说，这不是伪造一个声音。而是真正关于身体，身体移动的方式。我知道这是许多人要挂断电话的地方。现在，你应该看看。我正坐在椅子边缘。你在对她的戏剧书呆子心说话。是的，我听到了。你是在你的身体里塑造了你的角色，那个身体在我的身体里启发了你的声音。所以它来自整个身体。它不仅仅始于你的喉咙。没。错。而且这种方式，这种
speaking sort of becomes sort of a manifestation of that, right? But for Kevin, my idea was two things. One is that he's not aware of his size. So hence me like bumping into it. There's no that that was one thing. And the second thing was that if you imagine my torso, right, he didn't rotate his hips side to side. So if he needed to look in one direction, right, his whole body then would have to turn like shuffle step to go in in that direction. But let me be clear. There was a progression to the to the development of the character to write. And so I get asked sometimes like your voice kind of
说话方式某种程度上成为了那种表现形式，对吧？但对于凯文，我的想法是两点。第一点是，他没有意识到自己的体型。因此导致我撞到东西。没有，那是第一点。第二点是，如果你想象我的躯干，对吧，他不会左右扭动臀部。所以如果他需要往一个方向看，对吧，他的整个身体就必须转动，比如用小碎步朝那个方向走去。但让我明确一点。角色的发展是有过程的，对吧？所以我有时会被问到，你的声音从
changed from, you know, season one and and and through the show. And so my justification was in season one, Kevin was very, very nervous and scared of the cameras. And so when the cameras were around, he retreated into his shell like a turtle. And then as he became more comfortable or became even friendly with some of the crew, more of his true personality came out. Oh, I like that. I like that too. I think that's very good. Well, listen, should we talk about this famous chili cold open? I mean, Brian, we have got to I brought my Kevin's chili mug. I am here for it. So I brought chili for lunch today. Did
第一季到整个剧集发生了一些变化。所以我的理由是，在第一季中，凯文非常非常紧张，害怕摄像机。所以当摄像机在周围时，他像乌龟一样缩回了自己的壳里。然后随着他变得更自在，或者甚至和一些剧组人员成了朋友，他更多的真实性格显露出来了。哦，我喜欢那样。我也喜欢那样。我觉得这非常好。好吧，听着，我们该讨论这个著名的辣椒冷开场吗？我是说，布赖恩，我们必须，我带来了我的凯文辣椒马克杯。我为此而来。所以我今天午餐带了辣椒。你
you really? I did. If you can believe it. That's how on brand we are today. So so many people wrote in about this cold open, Brian, it is so beloved as you know, but it is also only 36 seconds long. I clocked it. And here is how it is described on Dunderpedia, which I thought was kind of amazing. It says the cold open with Kevin's chili has become one of the iconic moments of the show. It takes a low status character, offers him a high status moment, and then mercilessly takes it away. People relate to the moment of private embarrassment and the desperation of trying to rescue something that cannot be saved. The
真的带了？我带了。如果你能相信的话。我们就是这么契合品牌。所以，有这么多人写信来谈论这个冷开场，布赖恩，它正如你所知那样深受喜爱，但它也只有36秒长。我计时了。以下是邓德百科全书对它的描述，我觉得这有点神奇。上面写着，带有凯文辣椒的冷开场已经成为该剧的标志性时刻之一。它把一个低地位的角色带到一个高地位的时刻，然后毫不留情地把它夺走。人们对这种私密的尴尬时刻以及试图拯救无法挽救的东西的绝望感产生共鸣。这个
scene teeters between comedy and heartbreak in 36 seconds. Yeah, you know, people come up to me all the time. That's the moment that that more often than not is is referred to. And there are now for me two types of people. There are some people who are like, Oh my God, that is so hilarious. I love it. And then there are people who say like, I can't watch it. It breaks my heart. I feel so bad for Kevin. Now, I think in truth, it's somewhere in the middle. Like I think that I think that there's both. I think, you know, there's some physical comedy, but I think with a heartbreaking moment. I never knew. I
场景在36秒内在喜剧和心碎之间摇摆不定。是的，你知道，人们总是来找我。那是被提及最多的时刻。现在对我来说有两种人。有些人会说，哦天哪，太搞笑了。我太喜欢了。还有一些人说，我没法看。这让我心碎。我为凯文感到难过。现在，我觉得真相介于两者之间。就像我觉，我认为两者兼有。我认为，你知道，有一些肢体喜剧，但我认为伴随着一个心碎的时刻。我从来不知道。我
mean, never could have imagined that that one moment that was shot alone with nobody else around would would become what it has today. Well, we got a fan mail flurry of emails. I daresay blizzard. This is by the way, this is a genoterminology. She has a few. I've claimed some phrases. You have, we both have, but the fan mail flurry slash blizzard fan mail flurry. What can you tell us about shooting this? Because it is just a voiceover with your action of carrying this big pot of beloved chili up some stairs. You're
是说，从来没想过那个独自拍摄、周围没有其他人的时刻会变成今天的样子。好吧，我们收到了大量的粉丝邮件。我敢说是一场暴风雪。顺便说一句，这是珍娜的术语。她有一些。我宣称了一些短语。你有的，我们都有，但粉丝邮件狂潮斜杠暴风雪，粉丝邮件狂潮。关于拍摄这个，你能告诉我们什么吗？因为这只是一段画外音，伴随着你端着一大锅心爱的辣椒走上楼梯的动作。你在
bringing it into the office. It's we're told this is an annual event. You've brought in your chili and then it spills everywhere and you try desperately to clean it up. How did you do it? I'm tremendously proud of this now that the actual main portion was was one take the spill. That's what we heard one take the spill was one take. So they had done obviously some prep, right? Cause this was going to be a mess. There was no question. This was going to be a mess. And we'd rehearsed it, how it was going to go. Obviously it was all about the moment of spill having that look and
把它带进办公室。我们被告知这是一年一度的活动。你带了你的辣椒，然后它到处都是，你拼命想把它清理干净。你是怎么做到的？我现在为此感到无比自豪，实际上主要部分是一条过，辣椒酱泼洒的那部分。那是我们听说的，泼洒那部分是一条过。所以他们显然做了一些准备，对吧？因为这会是一团糟。毫无疑问。这会是一团糟。我们排练过，它将如何进行。显然，这一切都关于泼洒的那一刻，让那种外观和
feel as realistic as possible, right? And that it happened in the, you know, we didn't have marks on the show, but it happened in generally the correct place for the cameras to be able to pick that up, right? So Phil Shea came to me like kind of like a secret like back channel meeting. And he says, um, all right, so just so you know, we only have three pieces of carpet. So we can't, we can't do any more than that. And the carpet in case there was an accident was from the front door around, let's call it Pam's reception desk, all the way to the Dwight and Jim clump. I mean, it was a huge piece of the carpet that
感觉尽可能真实，对吧？而且它发生在，你知道，我们在剧中没有标记，但它通常发生在正确的地方，以便摄像机能够捕捉到，对吧？所以菲尔·谢伊像进行秘密暗中会议一样来找我。他说，嗯，好吧，所以你要知道，我们只有三块地毯。所以我们不能，我们不能再多了。如果发生意外，地毯是从前门绕过，我们姑且称之为帕姆的前台，一直到德怀特和吉姆的区域。我的意思是，这是一大块地毯，
replicated the carpet that existed there and that they laid down and tacked in and made it appear as though that was the carpet. And they said they had three pieces of it and that was it. So we needed to go. So what I have said to many people is that that was all planned for. Cleaning me wasn't really, that wasn't really, no one had any idea what would happen. Cause I was stained like I was your hands were like orange. And I remember probably my last public shower, but there were like, it felt like 14 people in the shower with me, like peeling off clothes and handing me towels to get it out of my eyes and hair
复制了那里存在的地毯，他们把它铺上、固定好，让它看起来就像那是地毯一样。他们说他们有三块，仅此而已。所以我们需要继续。所以我对很多人说过的是，那都是计划好的。清理我可不是，那真的不是，没有人知道会发生什么。因为我身上有污渍，就像你的手是橙色的一样。我记得可能是我最后一次公开淋浴，但感觉淋浴间里有14个人和我在一起，剥掉衣服，递给我毛巾，好把它从我的眼睛和头发里弄出来
and everything. Um, but yes, it was the actual spilling of it was, was one. And did it smell? Cause Phil Shea said they just used a gazillion cans of actual chili. I mean, it was that is spicy chili. Did you like put your head on the pillow that night and still smell chili? I can tell you, he smelled at dinner. Yeah, that's what I was about to say. So Angela and Oscar and I did regular dinners where it was like, okay, let's, let's dress up a little, like, let's look like real people, uh, take
还有一切。嗯，不过是的，实际洒出来的那一下，确实是一个。而且有味道吗？因为菲尔·谢伊说他们只用了一大堆真正的辣椒。我的意思是，那真的是很辣的辣椒。那天晚上你把头枕在枕头上时，还能闻到辣椒味吗？我告诉你，他在晚宴上闻起来有。是的，这就是我正要说的。所以安吉拉、奥斯卡和我经常举行常规晚宴，当时的感觉就是，好吧，让我们稍微打扮一下，看起来像正常人，呃，脱下
off our Dunder Mifflin clothes and let's go to a nice dinner. This particular night we had, and it was planned for months ahead when we were going to Mastros in Beverly Hills. Very nice. Steakhouse, very fancy. We did not mess around with these accountant dinners. Yeah. No, we did not mess around. And, and so of course, cause I was, that was the night we were filming this. So everybody else got to leave early that they were, you know, Angela got
我们邓德米夫林的衣服，去吃顿丰盛的晚餐。这个特定的晚上我们有，而且是提前几个月就计划好的，我们要去贝弗利山庄的马斯特罗餐厅。非常棒。牛排馆，非常高级。我们在这些会计师晚宴上可不含糊。是的。不，我们绝对不含糊。所以当然，因为我是，那是我们拍摄这一天。所以其他人都可以早点走，他们，你知道，安吉拉去
to curl her hair or whatever. And so I, so I show up with free time. If I get to go some more fancy, I'm curling my damn hair. Brian knows. That's Texas for you. That's the thing. I, so I show up and know Oscar is the one, cause I think you and I are a little more, I don't want to hurt Oscar's feelings to be always listening, but there's always a seafood tower. Oscar orders it every time it is obnoxious. It takes up the whole people. A huge lobs, like crap, like seafood and like oysters. Oysters.
卷了她的头发什么的。所以我，所以我有空就赶到了。如果我能去更高级的地方，我肯定会卷我的卷毛。布赖恩知道。这就是得克萨斯风格。就是这样。所以，我到了，奥斯卡是那个，因为我觉得你和我稍微更，我不想伤害奥斯卡的感情总是听着的，但总有一个海鲜塔。奥斯卡每次都点，这太讨厌了。占了整张桌子。巨大的龙虾，螃蟹，海鲜，还有生蚝。生蚝。
Oh yeah. The whole, he gets the whole, he's like, yeah, we should do the tower. It comes like, and it's, it's like, like steam or smoke is coming off of it cause there's so much dry ice and fanfare. Yes. Yes. This is true. So I said, this is a hundred percent true. So I sit down and my hands, I couldn't not smell chili. So now here's an appetizing. Your fingernails were orange, Brian, cause you were, you were, you had gotten it a little bit off your hands, but my memory was your hands were still tinted this weird color, but your fingernails, forget it. They were orange.
哦，是的。整个，他点了整个，他就像，是的，我们应该点那个塔。端上来的时候，就像，就像蒸汽或烟雾从上面冒出来，因为有那么多的干冰和噱头。是的。是的，这是真的。所以我说，这百分之百是真的。所以我坐下来，我的手，我无法不闻到辣椒味。所以现在这里有个开胃菜。你的指甲是橙色的，布赖恩，因为你当时，你手上沾的已经弄掉了一点，但我的记忆是你的指甲仍然染着这种奇怪的颜色，至于你的指甲，别提了。它们是橙色的。
Done. Done. So imagine that going into a crab leg with, and then you bring it to your mouth and there's just, you're smelling really bad canned chili. Let's just put it that way. Yeah. It was, it was, it, I, it was probably, there was, there was probably some tint for, for a couple of days, but the smell for sure, at least 24 hours. Well, I have another question about the cold open. Is it true that the choice to try to clean up the chili with various paperwork was an improvisation in the moment where you're grabbing stuff? I mean, that's amazing.
完了。完了。所以想象一下，拿着这个去抓蟹腿，然后你把它送到嘴里，那里只有，你闻到的只有非常糟糕的罐头辣椒。我们只能这么说。是的，它，它，它，我，它可能，可能有一些染色，持续了几天，但气味绝对至少持续了24小时。好吧，关于冷开场我还有另一个问题。选择用各种文件试图清理辣椒是你在抓东西时当场即兴发挥的吗？我的意思是，那太棒了。
I love the desperation. The folders. Once I was on the ground, I got to play a little, right? And so I just sort of started trying other things. And look, there are a lot of fans who have fallen in love with Kevin to watching the show. And I attribute that to everyone's innate desire to, to win one. Yes. And how difficult it is to, to find those little successes. Brent Forrester also said that he thinks they have about eight minutes of footage of you on the ground in the chili. Eight minutes. Think about that, you guys. Eight minutes is a long time to be rolling around in some chili.
我喜欢那种绝望感。文件夹。一旦我倒在地上，我就能稍微发挥一下了，对吧？所以我只是开始尝试其他事情。看，有很多粉丝在看剧的过程中爱上了凯文。我把这归功于每个人内心深处想要赢一次的渴望。是的。以及找到那些小小的成功是多么困难。布伦特·福斯特还说，他在想，他们大概有关于你在辣椒里躺在地上的八分钟素材。八分钟。想想看，伙计们。八分钟在辣椒里打滚是很长的时间。
It was a lot. I know that I tried a variety of slips, which people thought was, was funny. I remember trying, I remember trying that, but you have to remember again, it, I remember standing by a monitor as like clothes were beginning to be taken off me to watch it. Right. And again, Oh yeah. Cause you could do that. You could like rewind the tape and watch it back and decide, did we have it or not? Correct. They didn't use that capability on a daily basis, but on a major scene where you needed to, you know, there was going to be a huge reset. Yeah. And so I remember even, you
这可真不少。我知道我尝试了各种各样的滑倒，人们觉得这很搞笑。我记得我尝试过，我记得我尝试过这个，但你必须再次记住，它，我记得站在监视器旁，当衣服开始从我身上脱下来观看它的时候。对。而且再次，哦，是的。因为你可以那样做。你可以像倒带磁带一样回放并决定，我们拍到了还是没拍到？没错。他们不会每天都使用这种功能，但在需要你，你知道的，会有一次重大重置的重要场景上。是的。所以我甚至记得，你
know, watching it and me feeling good about it, but me feeling good about it doesn't really matter. Right. And I remember going into the showers, not knowing if, you know, cause right, like Laverne and Debbie are great hair and makeup people, like they're all standing by ready to try to totally reset me to go again. And, you know, they had obviously multiple outs, you know, you know, of the same outfit, et cetera. So yeah, I remember that moment about like, please, please, I think we have it. I think we're good. All right, Brian, we also ask everyone this question. What did you take from the
知道，看着它，我对此感觉很好，但我对此感觉好不好其实并不重要。对。而且我记得走进淋浴间，不知道，你知道，因为对吧，就像拉弗恩和黛比是出色的发型和化妆师，就像他们都随时准备着试图彻底重置我然后再拍一次。并且，你知道，他们显然有多个备用，你知道，同样服装的备用，等等。所以是的，我记得那一刻，就像，求求你，求求你，我想我们拍到了。我想我们搞定了。好吧，布赖恩，我们也会问每个人这个问题。你从
set when you left? Well, I took a few things, right? So I took, I took the diploma, Kevin's or certificate of completion. So my first ever joke in the show when Kevin is described by Michael Scott, he says something like he's not a great accountant, but a pretty good entertainer. And they cut to a b-roll shot with me with me with my giant pencil, which sat on my desk then for all the years, which most people don't know is a piggy bank. It's, it's still empty, but I took that and I took my nameplate and I, you had a nameplate all these years. I didn't
剧组离开时拿了什么？嗯，我拿了几样东西，对吧？所以，我拿了，我拿了毕业证书，凯文的或结业证书。所以在剧中我的第一个笑话，当迈克尔·斯科特描述凯文时，他说他不是一个伟大的会计师，但却是一个相当不错的艺人。他们切换到一个花絮镜头，镜头里的我拿着我的巨型铅笔，那支铅笔后来在我的办公桌上放了多年，大多数人不知道的是，它其实是一个存钱罐。它，它依然是空的，但我拿了那个，我还拿了我的名牌，你这些年一直有个名牌。我没
realize you had a nameplate. I had a nameplate. I didn't have a nameplate. Well, here's the thing that's crazy. Does it say Kevin Malone? And here's the crazy thing, right? My desk was in a club. You couldn't even see it. No, it faced me. Like, why would I need it faced to remind you your name? Because it's not announced. You know, usually you have a nameplate, like if you have an office and someone walks in, they can see immediately what your name, like if you go into a bank, it's like, oh, this is Susie Marshall. Hi, Susie. No, it was a nameplate that faced me for 10 years. It makes no sense.
意识到你有一个名牌。我有一个名牌。我没有名牌。好吧，疯狂的事情是这样的。上面写着凯文·马隆吗？而这里疯狂的事情是，对吧？我的桌子在一个角落里。你甚至看不到它。不，它朝向我。为什么我需要它朝向我来提醒你你的名字？因为它是倒着的。你知道，通常你有一个名牌，就像如果你有一个办公室，有人走进来，他们可以立即看到你的名字，就像如果你走进一家银行，就会觉得，哦，这是苏茜·马尔歇。嗨，苏茜。不，那是一个朝向我自己的名牌，放了10年。这根本说不通。
Behind a piece of glass. Behind it. Yes, what I'm saying is you would have to sit in my lap to see the nameplate. This is why we didn't know we had one. It makes no, no, I know. There was no thing. So yeah, I took the nameplate. I took the, the, the pencil and I, I took the jar of them. Oh, yes. I love that. This has been so awesome. It's been so wonderful to talk to you, Brian. Yeah. Thank you for letting us interview you. You make your living interviewing people and now you have a book out. Tell us about your book.
在一块玻璃后面。在它后面。是的，我的意思是，你得坐在我腿上才能看到那个名牌。这就是为什么我们不知道我有一个。这根本没有，没有，我知道。根本没有那回事。所以是的，我拿了名牌。我拿了，那个，铅笔，还有，我拿了那一罐。哦，是的。我太喜欢这个了。和你聊天太棒了，太美妙了，布赖恩。是的。谢谢你让我们采访你。你以采访别人为生，现在你出了一本书。给我们讲讲你的书吧。
Welcome to Dunder Mifflin. The, the, I mean, we're out in time for the holidays. This is prime holiday shopping moment, everyone. Listen up. This is, this is stocking stuff or material. Brian, I've seen the book. You're not getting that book into a stocking. Well, it's thick. That's what she said. There you go. It's a thick gift. It is. With two C's. All right. Okay. Okay. So tell us about it. Welcome to Dunder Mifflin. It is, you know, gosh, now a couple of years. I have been working on constructing a full oral history of the office and, and, and what happened,
欢迎来到邓德米夫林。这本，我的意思是，我们在假期前及时出版了。这是绝佳的假期购物时刻，各位。听好了。这是，这是圣诞袜里礼物的绝佳材料。布赖恩，我看过这本书。你可把那本书塞不进圣诞袜里。嗯，它很厚。她就是这么说的。给你。这是一本厚重的礼物。确实。带有两个C。好的。好吧。好吧。所以给我们讲讲吧。《欢迎来到邓德米夫林》。它，你知道，天哪，现在已经几年了。我一直在致力于构建一部关于《办公室》的完整口述历史，以及，以及，以及发生了什么，
and specifically for me, it was about a question, right? And the question was very simply, we were, we were a big show when we were on, right? We were, we were the number one scripted show on NBC for most of the time that we were on the air. But what has happened since, as you all know, the success, the huge success of your podcast, that, that the show is so much bigger now than it ever was. And my question was, why now seven, eight years since we've filmed a scene, why is this show now the undisputed champion of, of viewers in, in, in the world? Why are more people watching this show than any other show? And so for me, it was about going back to look at what happened. What, what, why did this happen? Was it about the construction of the cast? Was it about
特别是对我和我来说，它是关于一个问题的，对吧？这个问题非常简单，我们在播的时候，我们是一部大剧，对吧？在我们播出的绝大多数时间里，我们是NBC收视率第一的剧本节目。但后来发生了什么，正如你们所知，你们播客的成功，巨大的成功，使得这部剧现在比以往任何时候都要宏大得多。而我的问题是，为什么现在距离我们拍摄一个场景已经过去了七、八年，为什么这部剧现在成为了无可争议的全球观众冠军？为什么看这部剧的人比看任何其他剧的人都多？所以对我和我来说，就是要回过头来看看发生了什么。什么，为什么会这样？是因为演员阵容的构建吗？是因为
the aesthetic that was chosen originally by, by Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant and through Greg Daniels and Ken Quapas. So it's, it's really sort of a, a macro version of, of what happened. So I'm super excited and proud of the book and, and, and can't wait. And is that like an overview? Is it like a collection of interviews, like from your podcast, The Oral History of the Office? It's a little bit of everything yet really goes back and, and traces my journey of, of me attempting to answer this question. So it goes into, into today as well and the legacy of the show. And, but I went back to Scranton, like a real journalist, went back to Scranton and met with a lot of our old friends from there to talk about how, you know,
里奇·热维斯、斯蒂芬·麦钱特最初选择的美学，以及通过格雷格·丹尼尔斯和肯·奎帕斯呈现的美学？所以它，它真的有点像所发生事情的宏观版本。所以我对这本书超级兴奋和自豪，而且，而且，迫不及待了。那它是一个概述吗？它是一系列采访的集合吗？就像你的播客《办公室的口述历史》那样？它有点像所有这些的结合，但真正回过头来，追踪了我试图回答这个问题的旅程。所以它也延伸到了今天以及这部剧的传奇色彩。而且，我回到了斯克兰顿，像一个真正的记者一样，回到了斯克兰顿，与那里的许多老朋友见面，谈论这部剧是如何，你知道的，
the show was influenced directly from them and, and how the show has really changed that town. So it's a, it's a, it's a comprehensive look, but I think, I think, I think fans will really enjoy it. I think that's fantastic. I'll make sure you get a copy. Well, thank you. Signed, I hope. Do I get a signed copy? Yeah. You're not saying yes. Yes. Okay. Brian, you have another announcement. Well, listen, I have a podcast, The Office Deep Dive. And next year, January 4th, coming up, I'm going to be extending and transitioning to a new podcast off the beat with Brian Baumgartner coming in January. So I've loved talking to all the folks on the office, right? Having lengthy discussions, but really talking about the moments
直接受到他们的影响的，以及这部剧是如何真正改变那个小镇的。所以它是一个全面的视角，但我认为，我认为，我认为粉丝们会真的很喜欢它。我觉得这太棒了。我一定确保你拿到一本。好的，谢谢。希望有签名。我能拿到一本签名版吗？会的。你没有说“好”。好的。好吧，布赖恩，你还有另一个宣布。嗯，听着，我有一个播客，《办公室深度剖析》。明年1月4日即将到来，我将扩展并过渡到一个新的播客，《与布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳一起打破常规》，将于1月推出。所以，我喜欢和《办公室》的所有人交谈，对吧？进行长时间的讨论，但真正谈论的是那些时刻
in between the moments that is mostly covered by other press. So starting next year, I'm going to be talking to your other favorite stars from TV, like Modern Family, Cheers, Seinfeld, Fresh Prince of Bel Air, whoever. And we're going to be focusing on, on important moment in these stars lives that, that happened off the beat. I had a French director who told me, which is really applicable to the office, by the way, you can steal this, that comedy, real comedy happens off the beat. And so for me, the moments that I want to talk to people about are the moments that happened in between the important moments, the things that lead to those big moments that everyone else is covering. So I'm super excited to be expanding
介于那些主要被其他媒体报道的时刻之间的时刻。所以从明年开始，我将与你们来自其他电视节目的最爱明星交谈，比如《摩登家庭》、《干杯酒吧》、《宋飞传》、《新鲜王子妙事多》等等。我们将专注于这些明星生活中发生在“幕后”的重要时刻。我曾有一位法国导演告诉我，顺便说一句，这非常适用于《办公室》，你们可以偷用这个，喜剧，真正的喜剧发生在不经意间。所以对我和我来说，我想和人们谈论的时刻是那些发生在重要时刻之间的时刻，是那些导致每个人都在报道的那些宏大时刻的事情。所以我超级兴奋能够从
from the office. Obviously, we'll keep checking in with the office, but talking to people from, from your other favorite television shows. That is fantastic, Brian. We can't wait to hear it. It's going to be great. Thank you so much. I appreciate it. All right, bombers, we love you so much. Thank you again, Brian, for this generous interview. Thanks for coming on Office Ladies. Thank you so much for having me. Congratulations to everything that you guys are doing. I'm so, so happy and proud of you both. And I love you so, so much. Love you, B. It's going to make me cry. I know. We love you, Brian. Well, I loved our interview with Brian. I loved every second. It just made me miss us all hanging
《办公室》扩展出去。显然，我们会继续关注《办公室》，但也会与你们其他最喜欢的电视节目中的人交谈。这太棒了，布赖恩。我们迫不及待想听听了。这一定很棒。非常感谢。我很感激。好的，鲍姆加特纳们，我们太爱你们了。再次感谢布赖恩接受这个慷慨的采访。谢谢你来到《办公室辣妈》。非常感谢邀请我。祝贺你们正在做的一切。我为你们两个感到无比的高兴和自豪。我非常非常爱你们。爱你们，B。这快要让我哭了。我知道。我们爱你，布赖恩。嗯，我很喜欢我们对布赖恩的采访。我喜欢每一秒钟。这只是让我想念我们大家一起
out. Now, listen, in our interview with Brian, we talked a lot about his chili cold open. But if you can believe it, there are a few more things that we can share about it. So first of all, it was written by Aaron Scherr. And it was originally supposed to be the cold open for his script, Michael Scott Paper Company. But it ended up getting cut and moved to casual Friday. And there was a lot that our crew had to do to pull off this chili stunt. Yes. Our first assistant director, Rusty Mahmoud, shared in an interview, and I found this so interesting, Jenna. He said when he would read a script that had a cold open that was very prop intensive, it was immediately stressful for him. Oh, no. So while everyone else is laughing, he
闲逛的时光。现在，听着，在我们对布赖恩的采访中，我们聊了很多关于他的辣椒冷开场。但如果你能相信的话，关于它还有更多的事情我们可以分享。首先，它是由亚伦·谢尔写的。它最初本应是他剧本《迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司》的冷开场的。但它最终被删减并移到了休闲星期五。为了完成这个辣椒特技，我们的剧组必须做很多工作。是的。我们的第一助理导演鲁斯·马哈茂德在一次采访中分享道，詹娜，我觉得这太有趣了。他说当他读到剧本中有一个道具密集的冷开场时，他立刻感到了压力。哦，不。所以当其他人在笑时，他
could appreciate, right, the humor, but he also saw the hard work that was going to go behind it. Sure. He said his thought process in particular for this moment was, how do we drop a huge vat of chili without destroying our office? So they had a prop meeting. They had to discuss how big the vat was, where it was going to fall, all of that stuff that Brian talked about. Yeah. Randy added that on a practical note, they deliberately made this the very last scene of the week. So they could have time to clean it up before Monday, basically. Right. Because they didn't know how bad it was going to be. Oh my gosh. So even though they had done all these rehearsals, their concern was that
能够理解，对吧，其中的幽默，但他也看到了隐藏在背后的艰苦工作。确实。他说他针对这个时刻的思考过程是，我们如何在不毁掉办公室的情况下砸下一大桶辣椒？所以他们开了一个道具会议。他们必须讨论大桶有多大，它将落在哪里，所有布赖恩谈到的那些事情。是的。兰迪补充说，从实际角度来看，他们刻意将这安排为一周的最后一个场景。这样他们基本上可以在周一之前有时间清理它。对。因为他们不知道情况会有多糟。哦，天哪。所以尽管他们已经进行了所有的排练，但他们的担忧是
it's a vat of chili falling. It could hit at some weird angle and splatter across the wall, all over everything. Yeah. And I mean, just like think about the medicine ball that was never supposed to pop unless you hit it on the seam and the right space. And sure enough, that happened. It exploded. So they had to be prepared for everything. Randy also mentioned that the part where Kevin's just carrying the vat of chili up the stairs, they could not afford for a spill to happen. On the staircase. Yes. Oh gosh. So for that, they filled the pot with some sandbags because they did still want it to feel heavy. Right. And Brian, as you know, classically trained doctor. Yes. He has said numerous times that he didn't want to fake
这是一大桶落下的辣椒。它可能会以某种奇怪的角度撞击，并溅到墙上，溅到所有东西上。是的。我的意思是，就像想想那个医疗球，除非你击中接缝处的正确位置，否则它永远不应该爆裂。果不其然，事情发生了。它爆炸了。所以他们必须为一切做好准备。兰迪还提到，凯文正扛着一桶辣椒走上楼梯的那一部分，他们绝对不能发生任何泼洒。在楼梯上。是的。哦，天哪。所以为了那个，他们在锅里装了一些沙袋，因为他们确实仍然想让它感觉很重。对。而且布赖恩，如你所知，受过正规训练的演员。是的。他曾多次说过，他不想假装
carrying something heavy. He wanted to feel carrying something heavy. Yes. And then another little cheat they did was with the actual pot of chili. They thought they could make a fake bottom on that vat so that like the bottom third was filled with foam and then there would be a fake bottom to the pot. So it wouldn't be as much chili falling out. That would help avert a disaster. Yeah. Also, Rusty said that if they filled the whole thing with chili, it probably would have weighed over 50 pounds. So they needed something that Brian could carry through the door. And in the end, Rusty shared that it took about an hour to clean everything up and replace that carpet. One last thing I would like to share about this chili cold open is some of the dialogue that was
搬运重物。他想感受搬运重物的感觉。是的。然后他们做的另一个小把戏是用真正的辣椒锅。他们认为他们可以在那个大桶上做一个假底，这样底部三分之一塞满了泡沫，然后锅里会有一个假底。这样就不会有那么多的辣椒洒出来。这会有助于避免灾难。是的。另外，鲁斯说，如果他们把整个东西都装满辣椒，它可能重达50多磅。所以他们需要一个布赖恩可以搬着走过门的东西。最后，鲁斯分享说，他们花了大约一个小时才把所有东西清理干净并更换了地毯。关于这个辣椒冷开场，我最后想分享的一件事是
part of Kevin's voiceover that didn't make it in. Oh, this is in the shooting draft. And I guess it would have bought him more time to do different things. Sure. Right. But they trimmed it down. Here are two things Kevin would have said. Spiciness is to chili, what makeup is to a woman. I don't need a lot. I've got a sexy pot of chili. Okay. Okay. And now for the next one. Parsley is a tricky little beast, but it will tolerate some shade. Hmm. I don't know. It's just funny to me. And you know, the writer Anthony said they had so much fun coming up with spices and ingredients for Kevin to say. Oh, yeah. I'm sure that was a fun writer's room pitch. Well, now I think we can get into this episode, which has a great opening that was so fun to shoot.
部分凯文的画外音对话没有被采用。哦，这是在拍摄初稿中。我猜这本会为他争取更多时间去做不同的事情。当然。对吧。但他们把它精简了。以下是凯文原本会说的两句话。辣味之于辣椒，就像化妆之于女人。我不需要太多。我有一锅性感的辣椒。好的。好的。现在是下一句。欧芹是个棘手的小东西，但它能耐受一些阴凉。嗯。我不知道。这对我来说只是很有趣。你知道，编剧安东尼说他们在为凯文想香料和配料时玩得太开心了。哦，是的。我确信那是一个有趣的编剧室提案。好吧，现在我觉得我们可以进入这一集了，它有一个很棒的开场，拍起来太有趣了。
Pam and Ryan come in with this big circle thing with a question mark on it. Wait, wait, wait. Hold up. Before they even come in, you have got to go to one minute, one seconds. There is no plant at reception. Well, of course not. No plant. We know who's responsible for those plants and it's Pam. I know, but Aaron hasn't brought anything in. I just couldn't believe it. It didn't even feel like front reception to me. Oh, that means a lot. You're welcome. Also, can we please note Pam's khaki pants and taupe, kids? Is it taupe, beige? Really? Mm-hmm. They're not white? Nope. Scandalous. Very scandalous. As you were saying, they're holding this piece of paper with a big question mark on it. Who's behind it? Who is it? Who is it? Who is it? Who is it? Well, it's someone trying to
帕姆和瑞恩拿着这个带有问号的大圆圈进来了。等等，等等，等等。等一下。在他们进来之前，你必须去看一分钟零一秒。前台没有植物。好吧，当然没有。没有植物。我们知道谁负责那些植物，那就是帕姆。我知道，但亚伦没有带任何东西进来。我简直不敢相信。这对我来说甚至不觉得是前台。哦，这意义重大。不客气。还有，我们能注意一下帕姆的卡其色裤子和灰褐色，孩子们？是灰褐色，米色吗？真的吗？嗯-hmm。它们不是白色的吗？不是。太离谱了。非常离谱。正如你所说，他们拿着一张画着大问号的纸。谁在后面？是谁？是谁？是谁？是谁？嗯，是有人试图
bust through. It takes him several tries. I was cracking up at you and BJ, not Ryan and Pam, but I could see you and BJ when he was trying. There was real resistance. You guys were really like having to hold it steady. Well, people wanted to know, was it like scripted that he would have a hard time breaking through this paper or is that just what happened? Yes, it was scripted. Director Brent Forrester actually shared that this idea was based on something that I guess the writers had seen on YouTube of a high school cheerleading squad trying to bust through a paper banner, but they wouldn't rip and they end up in a pile or something. There's so many. There's so many. This clearly is the thing that happens. I have kind of witnessed this a
冲破。他试了好几次。你和BJ让我大笑，不是瑞恩和帕姆，但当我看到BJ尝试的时候，我能看到你。有真正的阻力。你们真的像不得不把它拿稳一样。好吧，人们想知道，他很难冲破这层纸是剧本里写好的，还是只是当时自然发生的？是的，是剧本写的。导演布伦特·福斯特实际上分享说，这个想法是基于我猜编剧们在YouTube上看到的一个高中拉拉队试图冲过纸横幅，但它们撕不破，结果撞成一堆或者什么的。有太多了。有太多了。这显然是会发生的事情。我有点目睹了这
little bit. Like live? Live, yes. And then sometimes what happens is the team is running behind the cheerleaders. Oh, no. I know. And then you hit that resistance and that, yeah. Phil Shea made six of those circles for Steve to bust through. He used butcher paper, which is heavier than regular paper, so it would actually be kind of tough. What was the circle, like a hula hoop or something? Yeah. We only had to do the scene twice though. So there's four extra circles sitting backstage that day. Of course, Michael is going to announce conference room five minutes. Oh, he's been in the office for 40 seconds and he's already calling the conference room. Conference room five minutes. In this conference room, he really invites the employees to say
一点。像现场？现场，是的。然后有时发生的是队伍在拉拉队员后面跑。哦，不。我知道。然后你遇到了那种阻力，然后，是的。菲尔·谢伊为史蒂夫做了六个这样的圆圈来冲破。他用了牛皮纸，比普通的纸更重，所以它实际上会有点硬。那个圆圈是什么，就像呼啦圈什么的吗？是的。不过我们只需要拍两次那个场景。所以那天后台有多余的四个圆圈。当然，迈克尔要宣布五分钟后开会。哦，他在办公室待了40秒就已经在叫开会了。五分钟后开会。在这个会议室里，他真的邀请员工们发表意见
whatever is on their mind. He wants an apology desperately. And this starts from my character at just a delightful storyline, which is every single person in the office loves Casual Friday, but Angela Martin hates it. That tracks for me. And finds it inappropriate. It is also in this meeting where Michael is going to let everyone know that Pam and Ryan are staying on in sales and they get to keep the clients. And people are not happy about that. One of my favorite lines of the episode is when Andy says, I call foul, sir. Well, Michael says people can file their complaints into the trash can. The complaint department. Jenna, did you notice in this scene that Pam is completely covered by her purple sweater and Phyllis is only in the plaid shirt?
无论他们心里在想什么。他非常想要一个道歉。而这一切都从我扮演的一个可爱角色开始，这个角色就是办公室里的每一个人都喜欢休闲星期五，但安吉拉·马丁讨厌它。这很符合她的性格。并且觉得很不合适。也是在这场会议上，迈克尔要让大家知道帕姆和瑞安将继续留在销售部，而且他们可以保留客户。人们对此很不高兴。我最喜欢本集的台词之一是安迪说：“我抗议，先生。”好吧，迈克尔说大家可以把投诉信扔进垃圾桶。投诉部门。珍娜，你有没有注意到在这场戏里，帕姆完全被她的紫色毛衣包裹着，而菲莉丝只穿着格子衬衫？
That was intentional because they don't want to mess up the reveal. Yes. And it's a bit of a cheat because you have to imagine that just because the audience hasn't seen Pam and Phyllis standing in their identical outfits, surely Pam and Phyllis have seen one another as they went into the conference room. Exactly. They've been there for most of the morning. But that brings us to the kitchen where Pam and Phyllis discover that they are in fact wearing the exact same outfit that they both liked on the mannequin at the mall. Pam says they got it at Boss Cove's at the Steamtown Mall. So, you know, I had to know. Is it a real store? Is Boss Cove's a real store? And is it at the Steamtown Mall? Well, let me tell you,
那是故意的，因为他们不想提前剧透。是的。这有点像个小把戏，因为你必须想象，仅仅因为观众还没有看到帕姆和菲莉丝穿着一模一样的衣服，帕姆和菲莉丝在走进会议室时肯定已经见过彼此了。没错。她们整个上午都在那儿。但这把我们带到了厨房，帕姆和菲莉丝在那里发现她们实际上穿着一模一样的衣服，那是她们俩在商场的模特身上都很喜欢的。帕姆说她们是在蒸汽镇购物中心的博斯科夫买的。所以，你知道的，我不得不去了解一下。这是一个真实的店吗？博斯科夫是一家真正的店吗？它在蒸汽镇购物中心吗？好吧，让我告诉你，
Boss Cove's is a real store and there is one at the Steamtown Mall. And I had to know a little bit about what the store is because they're very east coast. I'd never heard of it, right? Either. On the Boss Cove's website, it says it is a family-owned department store for over 100 years. And it is, in fact, America's largest family-owned department store. Oh! Yes, Jenna, are you ready for this? A little bit of background info on Boss Cove's. And this is on their website. At only 18 years old, Solomon Boss Cove left his family in Russia, immigrated to the United States in 1914. He settled in Reading, Pennsylvania. With a pack on his back and a few dollars he had, he began peddling household goods to the farm families in the surrounding area.
博斯科夫是一家真正的店，蒸汽镇购物中心就有一家。而且我很想了解一下这家店的背景，因为它们非常具有东海岸特色。我以前从未听说过，对吧？我也是。在博斯科夫的网站上，它说这是一个经营了100多年的家族百货公司。而且，它实际上是美国最大的家族百货公司。噢！是的，珍娜，你准备好了吗？关于博斯科夫的一些背景信息。这是来自他们的网站。所罗门·博斯科夫在年仅18岁时就离开了他在俄罗斯的家人，于1914年移民到美国。他在宾夕法尼亚州雷丁定居。背着一个背包和仅有的几美元，他开始向周边地区的农场家庭兜售日用品。
Like a door-to-door salesman? That's right. And he got a reputation of being very fair and very honest. The business grew, his reputation grew. He was able to buy dry goods and provide merchandise. And the first Boss Cove's department store was established. And it's still going strong today. Okay. Lady, hear me out. Next time we're in Scranton, we go to Boss Cove's at the Steamtown Mall and we buy matching outfits. Done! And then we go bowl and go to poor Richards. I mean, we have a lot of places to go. We got a lot of places to go. Well, we got a lot of mail about these matching outfits. So many questions on how they were chosen. And also, if I felt at all that this outfit was a little out of character for Pam, well,
就像一个上门推销员？没错。他赢得了非常公正和诚实的声誉。业务不断发展，声誉也越来越高。他能够购买干货并提供商品，第一家博斯科夫百货公司就这样成立了。而且直到今天它依然生意兴隆。好吧。女士，听我说。下次我们在斯克兰顿的时候，我们就去蒸汽镇购物中心的博斯科夫买情侣装。一言为定！然后我们去打保龄球，再去穷理查德酒吧。我的意思是，我们有很多地方要去。我们有很多地方要去。好吧，我们收到了很多关于这些情侣装的邮件。有这么多关于它们是如何被选中的问题。还有，如果我觉得这套衣服对帕姆来说有点不符合性格的话，那么，
I reached out to Alicia, our wardrobe designer for this episode. And she shared with me that this storyline was a very late addition to the script. She had very little time to figure out what this matching outfit will be. She said she normally would have made something from scratch because that's her. I mean, this woman is amazing at building clothing. Yeah. But because of time, she had to find existing pieces. So Alicia started by going to the stores where she would buy Phyllis's wardrobe. And she was really concerned about Phyllis feeling comfortable in this outfit. She shared that she had color palettes for all of our characters. And she looked at the color palettes for Pam and Phyllis. And she saw that we had a few overlapping colors. And our overlapping
我联系了本集的服装设计师艾莉西亚。她跟我分享说，这个故事情节是剧本非常后期的补充。她只有很少的时间来弄清楚这套情侣装会是什么样。她说她通常会从头开始制作，因为那就是她。我的意思是，这位女士非常擅长制作服装。是的。但由于时间紧迫，她不得不寻找现成的单品。于是艾莉西亚首先去了她会为菲莉丝购买服装的商店。她非常担心菲莉丝穿这件衣服会感到舒适。她分享说，她为我们所有的角色都准备了调色板。她查看了帕姆和菲莉丝的调色板。她看到我们有一些重叠的颜色。而我们的重叠
colors were mauve, mint, cocoa brown, navy and purple. I would dare say that purple was an overlapping color for the majority of the office. I think Alicia likes purple. Well, I had a purple breakdown of a whole scene. I think when we have Alicia on the podcast, we're going to ask her, what's your favorite color? Let's see if she says purple. I think she's going to say purple. So she said the first item she found was the plaid shirt. And she thought that was a good place to start. She said also our characters both tended to layer our clothes. And she thought though that there needed to be something that wasn't too Phyllis or too Pam about it. So she thought the little sweater shrug was another good crossover item. So that was her first choice of outfit.
颜色是紫红色、薄荷绿、可可棕、海军蓝和紫色。我敢说，紫色是办公室大多数人的重叠颜色。我想艾莉西亚喜欢紫色。好吧，我对一整场戏做过一个关于紫色的统计。我想当我们在播客中请到艾莉西亚时，我们会问她，你最喜欢的颜色是什么？让我们看看她是不是说紫色。我想她会说紫色。所以她说她找到的第一件单品是格子衬衫。她认为这是一个很好的起点。她还说，我们的角色都倾向于叠穿衣服。她认为需要有一些既不太像菲莉丝也不太像帕姆的东西。所以她认为那件小披肩是另一个很好的跨界单品。这就是她最初选择的服装。
And then she bought it in both of our sizes. And then she found two other outfits that she thought might work. Well, this is all happening at 9 p.m. as the mall is closing the night before we had to shoot this. Oh my gosh. That's how little time she had. She's like sprinting through the mall. Yes. So the next morning Phyllis came in for her fitting. And Alicia said the plaid shirt was the clear winner. I came in for my fitting. I thought it was really cute. They altered the top a little bit for me. You might notice that my version is a little more fitted in the chest. I will say looking back, this is not a fashionable outfit. It is not. Here's the thing. The plaid shirt is fine. It's the sweater. I don't know what you call that thing. It's not a shrug. She called
然后她买下了我们两个人的尺码。接着她又找到了另外两套她认为可能行得通的服装。好吧，这一切都发生在晚上9点，就在我们拍摄前一天的晚上，商场快要关门的时候。哦天哪。她只有这么少的时间。她就像在商场里冲刺一样。是的。所以第二天早上菲莉丝来试装。艾莉西亚说格子衬衫是绝对的赢家。我来试装时，我觉得它真的很可爱。他们为我把上衣稍微修改了一下。你可能会注意到我的版本在胸部更修身一些。我必须说，回过头来看，这不是一套时尚的衣服。确实不是。事情是这样的。格子衬衫很好。问题是那件毛衣。我不知道你怎么称呼那东西。它不是披肩。她称
it a shrug. Well, guess what? Just listen to the word shrug. Is that something you want to wear? Listen, back then those shrugs were a thing. They were. You can look it up. And capri pants were a thing. Oh yeah. So I think maybe this outfit has just not held up great over time, really. But at the same time, Pam has never been a real fashion forward gal. She saw something on a mannequin. She tried it. I do like looking back, trying to imagine how did Jim handle this back at the house when she's like, what do you think? Jim is like, it's great. It's different. How did what? Have you had that moment with your husband? Jim wore a knit tie for years. He also bought his parents' house that had a clown mounted to the wall, a clown painting.
它为披肩。好吧，你猜怎么着？听听“披肩”这个词。那是你想穿的东西吗？听着，那时候这种披肩确实很流行。确实如此。你可以查证一下。而且卡普里裤也很流行。哦，是的。所以我想也许这套衣服随着时间的推移并没有经受住考验，真的。但与此同时，帕姆从来都不是一个真正追求时尚的姑娘。她看到模特身上有一件，就试穿了。回想起来，我真的很喜欢去想象吉姆在家里是怎么处理这事的，当她问：“你觉得怎么样？”吉姆说：“很好。很特别。”怎么样的？你和你丈夫有过这种时刻吗？吉姆戴了多年的针织领带。他还买下了他父母的房子，里面墙上挂着一个丑角，一幅丑角画。
I don't know that Jim has his finger on the pulse of fashion. I guess you're right. I think he probably thinks Pam looks cute in everything. Yeah. Lee has tried that for me when I'm like, okay, what do you think this outfit? He'll say, I think you look beautiful in everything. I'll say, well, obviously, I'm not getting this outfit because if I looked good, you'd just tell me I looked good. He'd be like, no, I'm telling you, I think you're beautiful in everything. I think you're beautiful. I love you. And I'm like, okay, okay, take a picture of me. I'm going to send it to Angela. I need a real opinion. This is true. I get whenever Jim has to buy an outfit for anything,
我不知道吉姆对时尚有没有什么敏感度。我想你是对的。我想他可能觉得帕姆穿什么都可爱。是的。李在我问“好吧，你觉得这套衣服怎么样？”时也试过这样。他会说：“我觉得你穿什么都好看。”我会说：“好吧，很明显，我不会买这套衣服，因为如果我穿好看的话，你就会直接告诉我我好看。”他会说：“不，我是说真的，我觉得你穿什么都好看。我觉得你很美。我爱你。”而我会说：“好吧，好吧，给我拍张照。我要发给安吉拉。我需要一个真正的意见。”这倒是真的。每当吉姆需要为任何事情买衣服时，
for years. This is like over a decade now, I get a little photo shoot spread texted to me. Yes. And you ask my thoughts. What would you say if I sent you this outfit? I would say skip the purple shruggy thing. Keep the shirt, khaki pants are fine. You know, given when this episode aired. Okay. They're enough. Well, Phyllis has a ton of sass in this episode. Oh my gosh, she tells Pam that she looks like a trout. She says, close your mouth, sweetie. You look like a trout. This is an epic insult. I am telling you, that is like amazing. Could you imagine saying to someone, you look like a trout?
多年来都是如此。这大概已经有十多年了，我会收到一张发给我的照片拼图。是的。然后你问我的想法。如果我把这套衣服发给你，你会说什么？我会说跳过那个紫色的披肩。留着衬衫，卡其裤还可以。你知道的，考虑到这一集播出的时间。好吧，它们足够了。好吧，菲莉丝在本集里有很多俏皮话。哦天哪，她告诉帕姆她看起来像条鳟鱼。她说：“闭上嘴，亲爱的。你看起来像条鳟鱼。”这是一个史诗级的侮辱。我跟你说，这太棒了。你能想象对某人说“你看起来像条鳟鱼”吗？
No, I think it's like, you know how in your mind, you have like a fantasy argument with someone who you've always wanted to tell off, but maybe you're like me and you're not confrontational. This is fantasy moment. Close your mouth, sweetie. You look like a trout. This is going to take us to a scene where Angela is complaining to Toby, because Oscar has worn sandals and you can see his feet. Jenna, this scene was so much fun to do. I had so much fun yelling at Toby. And as I exit, I say, excuse me, oh, you're so educated, aren't you, Toby? So trained to deal with the hysterical woman. I had an improvisation that made it in. I yelled, I don't want to look at his feet. That was improv. Very good. Thank you.
不，我觉得这就像，你知道有时在你的脑海里，你会和某个你一直想斥责的人进行一场幻想中的争论，但也许你和我一样，不喜欢对抗。这是一个幻想时刻。“闭上嘴，亲爱的。你看起来像条鳟鱼。”这将把我们带到一个场景，安吉拉在向托比抱怨，因为奥斯卡穿着凉鞋，你能看到他的脚。珍娜，拍这场戏太有趣了。我冲托比大吼大叫得太开心了。当我退场时，我说：“打扰一下，噢，你真是有文化，对吧，托比？真懂得如何应付歇斯底里的女人。”我有一个即兴发挥被保留了下来。我大喊：“我不想看他的脚！”那是即兴发挥。非常好。谢谢。
But you guys, let's think about this for a second. Do you really want to look at men's feet at work or on an airplane? You guys that wear flip flops on airplanes. I get it. Maybe it's your vacation. You're going somewhere tropical. I don't know. When I see feet on a plane, it's weird. Do you take your shoes off on a plane? If you have on shoes and socks, will you take off your shoes if you have a long flight? I mean, it has to be a pretty long flight. I'm always cold, so I don't take my shoes off. You know what I bring? What? Slippers? Bring little like slipper socks. And so I'll take off my shoes and put on slipper socks. Just, I don't know. Just because I think it's rude to just be in like sock feet on a plane too. Yeah. It's a small space. You
但是你们大家，让我们仔细想想。你在工作时或者在飞机上真的想看男人的脚吗？你们这些在飞机上穿人字拖的人。我懂。也许那是你的假期。你要去某个热带地方。我不知道。当我在飞机上看到脚时，感觉很奇怪。你在飞机上会脱鞋吗？如果你穿着鞋袜，如果有长途飞行你会脱鞋吗？我的意思是，那必须是非常长的飞行。我总是很冷，所以我不会脱鞋。你知道我带什么吗？什么？拖鞋？带那种小拖鞋袜。所以我会脱下鞋子换上拖鞋袜。只是，我不知道。只是因为我觉得在飞机上光着脚或者只穿着袜子也很粗鲁。是的。那是一个小空间。你
don't wear your slipper socks into the bathroom though. You put your shoes back on. Yes. Oh, yes. Gross. I'm certain men are pissing all over the bath. Oh my God. I wipe that sucker down. I wipe it. I do like a cleaning before I go to the bathroom. For sure. Anyway, I'm just saying, is Angela- Oh, and just for the record, I do wash my hands when I exit an airplane washroom. Oh, thank God. I feel like I have to tell people now. Thank God. Every time, even if I just pee. Listen, we all know that Angela is the office bitch, but I think, I think, you know, maybe maybe open toad sandals for men on casual Friday. Maybe I would agree with her. I didn't disagree with her. There you go. Well, this leads Toby to have this talking head where he reveals that he
不会穿着拖鞋袜去洗手间吧。你会把鞋子穿回去。是的。哦，太恶心了。我敢肯定男人在洗手眼里到处小便。哦，天哪。我把那个混蛋擦干净。我擦。我去洗手间前会做一次清洁。肯定的。不管怎样，我是说，安吉拉是——哦，顺便说一句，我从飞机洗手间出来时确实洗手了。哦，谢天谢地。我觉得我现在必须告诉别人。谢天谢地。每一次，哪怕我只是小便。听着，我们都知道安吉拉是办公室里的刻薄鬼，但我觉得，我觉得，你知道，也许在休闲星期五男士穿露趾凉鞋。也许我会同意她的看法。我并不反对她。这就对了。好吧，这导致托比有了一段镜头独白，在独白中他透露自己
was in the seminary for a year. And there's a photo of him that we've never seen before. No. Randy shared that that was like a green screen photo. They took a picture at the church where Phyllis got married and then they superimposed Paul onto that picture for that seminary photo. But he says that he dropped out to have sex with a woman named Kathy. He followed her to Scranton, got a job in HR, but now they're divorced. Now, this is very much at odds with that deleted scene that you told us about from local ad where he says he worked in advertising for three years before joining Dunder Mifflin. I know. But that was deleted. So we decided if something was deleted, it didn't really happen in the world of the office. That's how we're saying it. Yes.
在神学院待了一年。有一张他的照片是我们以前从未见过的。没有。兰迪分享说那是一张绿幕照片。他们在菲莉丝结婚的教堂拍了一张照片，然后把保罗的形象叠加到那张照片上作为神学院的照片。但他说他退学是为了和一个叫凯茜的女人发生性关系。他跟着她去了斯克兰顿，在人力资源部找到了一份工作，但现在他们离婚了。现在，这与你之前告诉我们的关于《地方广告》中那个被删减的片段大相径庭，他在那里说他在加入邓德米夫林之前从事了三年广告工作。我知道。但那段被删除了。所以我们决定，如果某个情节被删除了，它在《办公室》的世界里就没有真正发生过。这就是我们的说法。是的。
I want you guys to know in the background of this talking head over Toby's shoulder, I saw Leslie eating. What? If you watch it, go to five minutes, one second. I mean, Leslie had to be in the background for so long during all of these talking heads. He was such a trooper. I think he just got hungry. So Stanley's having a snack at his desk. It works. So next up, we're going to start to see a little bit of how Michael might be giving preferential treatment to Pam and Ryan. Well, he goes and gets Ryan a soda. And then Jenna, what does he get, Pam? He gives Pam a Fiji water. I am telling you, they were sponsoring the show. How are they not sponsoring the show? How many episodes now is this? This is the third Fiji
我想让你们知道，在这个托比肩膀后面的独白背景里，我看到莱斯利在吃东西。什么？如果你仔细看，调到5分1秒。我的意思是，在所有这些独白期间，莱斯利不得不在背景里待那么长时间。他真的是个硬汉。我想他只是饿了。所以斯坦利在办公桌前吃零食。这很合情理。接下来，我们将开始看到一些迈克尔如何对帕姆和瑞安给予优待。好吧，他去给瑞安买了一罐苏打水。然后，珍娜，他给帕姆买什么了？他给帕姆买了一瓶斐济水。我跟你说，他们是在赞助这个节目。他们怎么没有赞助这个节目？这已经是第几集了？这是第三次
water bottle spotting. Once again, the label is facing away from camera, a deliberate move by Steve Carell as he sets it down. I asked Randy about it. Did you? Were we getting some secret Fiji dough? No. He says he has no idea why these Fiji waters are showing up on set. He said he was going to investigate it. But he said we did not have a deal with Fiji that he knows about. However, he did say this, which I thought was really interesting. He said anytime he ever is line producing something that takes place on a boat, they always use Fiji water because they don't roll. It doesn't roll. Yeah. Well, I feel like for me, this Fiji water on the set of the office is like that Starbucks coffee. Remember in Game of Thrones? Yes. How
出现斐济水瓶。又一次，标签背对着镜头，这是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔放下它时的一个故意动作。我问过兰迪这件事。是吗？我们是不是拿到了什么秘密的斐济水资金？没有。他说他不知道这些斐济水为什么会出现在片场。他说他会去调查一下。但他表示据他所知我们并没有和斐济达成协议。不过，他说了一件事，我觉得非常有趣。他说任何时候只要他担任在船上拍摄的节目的现场制片人，他们总是使用斐济水，因为它们不会滚动。它不会滚动。是的。好吧，我觉得对我来说，《办公室》片场出现的这瓶斐济水就像《权力的游戏》里的星巴克咖啡一样。还记得吗？是的。怎么会
there was the Starbucks coffee? I do remember. I'm like obsessed with like, what's up with this Fiji water? Dwight is going to notice this special treatment that Michael is giving them. It's time for him to pass out a secret memo with Invisible Ink. Yes. Where did he get the Invisible Ink? You might like to know. He says it's urine. Yeah. I'm guessing his urine. Yes. He's very frustrated because people don't know how to reveal the Invisible Urine message. Right. They're not savvy to the Invisible Ink thing. Well, this got me wondering. Oh no. I googled, can you use urine as Invisible Ink? Oh my God. Really and truly at the end of this podcast, I want to print our search history and put it in a frame. Please do. Well, I'll have you know that, yes, urine
有星巴克咖啡？我记得。我简直迷上了，这瓶斐济水是怎么回事？德怀特注意到了迈克尔给他们的这种特殊待遇。是时候让他分发一份用隐形墨水写的秘密备忘录了。是的。他从哪里弄来的隐形墨水？你可能会想知道。他说那是尿液。是的。我猜是他的尿液。是的。他非常沮丧，因为人们不知道如何显示隐形尿液信息。没错。他们不懂隐形墨水的把戏。好吧，这让我感到好奇。哦，不。我谷歌了一下，你可以用尿液当隐形墨水吗？哦，天哪。在这期播客结束时，我真的想把我们的搜索历史打印出来并装进框里。请务必这么做。好吧，我要告诉你的是，没错，尿液
can be used as Invisible Ink and I discovered the most fascinating story of people using urine as Invisible Ink and I'm going to share it with you now. Oh, okay. I'm reclining and getting my cup of tea. I'm settling in. All right. During World War II, there were a group of Polish prisoners who were taken to a Nazi death camp and they used their urine as Invisible Ink to write letters detailing the horrific experiences that were going on at the camp. They were a group of young Polish girls and women who had been part of the Polish underground resistance to the Nazi regime and they were captured. They were imprisoned and this group were called the Rabbits of Ravensbrook because, and this is horrible, they were subjected to extreme medical experiments
可以当隐形墨水使用，我发现了人们用尿液作隐形墨水的极其迷人的故事，我现在就分享给你们。哦，好吧。我正靠在椅子上，拿起了我的茶杯。我安顿下来了。好的。在二战期间，有一群波兰囚犯被带到纳粹集中营，他们用尿液作为隐形墨水写信，详细描述了集中营里发生的恐怖经历。她们是一群年轻的波兰女孩和妇女，曾参与波兰地下抵抗组织对抗纳粹政权，随后被捕。她们被关进监狱，这群人被称为“拉文斯布吕克的兔子”，因为——这太可怕了——她们遭受了极端的医学实验，
like rabbits. That's why they got this nickname. However, they were allowed to write letters to their families back home once a month, but the letters were heavily censored. One of these women remembered that when she was a child, her and her brother had read the series of books where people were writing messages in Invisible Ink. So they used their urine to write these secret messages and due to a reaction with the paper, the urine loses its color and becomes invisible, but then if you heat it up, it reveals what was written. And in her first letter to her brother, she wrote about these books that they read as kids and he figured out the code and knew how to reveal the hidden messages. So they came up with this code with their families, which was if the
就像兔子一样。这就是她们得到这个外号的原因。然而，她们被允许每个月给家里的亲人写一封信，但这些信件受到了严厉的审查。其中一位女性记起，当她还是个孩子的时候，她和哥哥曾读过一系列人们用隐形墨水写信的书籍。因此，她们用尿液来写这些秘密信息，由于与纸张发生反应，尿液会失去颜色并变得隐形，但如果你加热它，就会显现出写的内容。在她写给哥哥的第一信中，她写到了他们小时候读过的这些书，他猜出了密码，并且知道如何显示隐藏的信息。于是他们和家人想出了一套密码，那就是如果
hidden messages were revealed, the families would send back a letter with a little piece of blue string. And that's how they knew if their messages were being received. So eventually, the contents of these letters and the horrific details of the camp were broadcast on the radio and the camp was liberated by the Red Army and the four women who wrote the letters all survived. Their letters were used as evidence to prosecute the guards. Wow. And 77 years later, these letters can still be read because 27 of them are still readable and on display in a museum in Lublin. Oh my gosh. That is an amazing story. Amazing. I was completely riveted. I couldn't believe it. I couldn't believe it. Yeah, I'm just sort of speechless at the gravity
隐藏的信息被显示出来，家人们就会回信并附上一小段蓝色细绳。这就是他们如何得知自己的信息是否被收到的方式。最终，这些信件的内容和集中营的恐怖细节在电报上广播了，集中营被红军解放，写信的四位女性全部幸存。她们的信件被用作起诉看守的证据。哇。77年后，这些信件依然可以被阅读，因为其中27封仍然清晰可辨，并在卢布林的博物馆里展出。哦天哪。那真是一个令人惊叹的故事。太惊人了。我完全被迷住了。我简直不敢相信。我简直不敢相信。是的，对于那个故事的分量，我简直无言以对，
of that story and how it's amazing. I think we should take a break. Yes. And when we come back, we find out yet a new detail of Toby. What is Toby? Toby is like this onion. We're just peeling layers back about him. We're back and there is the snippet of a scene. It's just a tiny moment where Toby is trying to get Oscar to take his socks and he says they're clean. He was going to wear them to volleyball practice. Who the heck is Toby? Who is this person? Was he in a weekly volleyball game? Like he plays adult volleyball? All right. We got some fan mail that had a few theories on this. One of them being that it's going to be revealed in company picnic that Pam likes volleyball. Oh, is he trying to get good at volleyball to impress Pam? That is what
它是多么的惊人。我想我们应该休息一下。好的。当我们回来时，我们将发现关于托比的一个新细节。托比是什么？托比就像洋葱。我们只是在剥开关于他的层层外壳。我们回来了，这里有一个场景的片段。这只是一个小片场，托比正试图让奥斯卡拿走他的袜子，他说它们是干净的。他打算穿着它们去排球训练。到底谁是托比？这个人是谁？他参加每周一次的排球比赛吗？就像他打成人排球一样？好吧。我们收到了一些粉丝来信，里面有关于这的几个理论。其中之一是将在公司野餐中揭晓帕姆喜欢排球。哦，他在努力提高排球水平以给帕姆留下深刻印象吗？这就是
people were saying. That is so cute. That this volleyball game is coming up and maybe he wants to have something in common with Pam. Oh, I love that. Well, Dwight's secret message is not received. So he is going to just tell everybody who is a salesperson who isn't Pam or Ryan, go down to the warehouse. I love the scene in the warehouse. I thought it was such a great ensemble scene. It reminded me of how when Michael has to lead a conference room scene and everyone keeps getting him off track, it was much longer than what you see in the actual episode. And I really wanted you guys to hear the rest of the scene. Thank you all for coming. Now, please, everyone take a candle. We don't have time for candles. They think we're all in the bathroom. Skip the candles.
大家所说的。这太可爱了。排球比赛即将到来，也许他想和帕姆有共同语言。哦，我喜欢这样。好吧，德怀特发出的秘密信息没有被收到。所以他打算直接告诉每一个销售人员，除了帕姆和瑞安，去仓库集合。我很喜欢仓库里的这场戏。我觉得这是一场非常棒的群戏。它让我想起每当迈克尔必须领导一场会议，而每个人总是让他偏离正题时，那比你在实际剧集里看到的要长得多。我真的希望你们听到这场戏的其余部分。谢谢大家光临。现在，请大家每人拿一支蜡烛。我们没时间拿蜡烛。他们以为我们都在洗手间里。跳过蜡烛吧。
Let's cut to the chase. How annoying is this, huh? Do you mean what's going on today or this meeting? No, obviously what's happening at the meeting is not annoying. Only certain people in it are annoying. Can I take one of these candles home? Gentlemen, it's time to put our balls in the guillotine, as they say. Who has ever said that? Regional expression. I'm talking about going to Michael and telling him that we are ready to quit. Oh, boy, I don't know. Yeah, Dwight, what if he calls our block? Then we are gone because if we do nothing, then we fail and failure is not an option. Well, hold on now. Let's think this through. If we do nothing, at least we'll have our jobs. If we do nothing, we fail and failure is not an option. Well, to be clear, it is an option.
我们开门见山吧。这有多烦人，哈？你是说今天发生的事还是这场会议？不，很明显会议上发生的事并不烦人。只有里面某些人很烦人。我可以把这些蜡烛带回家一支吗？先生们，正如他们所说，是时候把我们的蛋蛋放到断头台上了。谁说过这话？地区俗语。我说的是去找迈克尔并告诉他我们准备辞职了。哦，天哪，我不知道。是的，德怀特，如果他顺着我们的话说怎么办？那我们就完蛋了，因为如果我们什么都不做，那么我们就失败了，失败不是选项。等等，让我们仔细想想。如果我们什么都不做，至少我们还有工作。如果我们什么都不做，我们就失败了，而失败不是选项。好吧，澄清一下，这是一个选项。
Not in my book. My book, the cover is failure is not an option. It is an option. Not in my book. Literally. What book? Did you write it? I could have watched that all day. Oh, that's when they would just let us keep talking and character. Yes. It's sort of like a long form improv exercise. Yes. Well, while all this is happening in the warehouse, Pam, Ryan and Michael are like best friends. They're up in Michael's office and they are giggling over this photo collage Michael has made. I mean, Ryan and Pam hated each other at Michael Scott Paper Company and now they're just like, it's like they, they're old war buddies or something. I loved it. I loved this dynamic. We had a
在我看来不是。我的书，封面就是失败不是选项。这是一个选项。在我看来不是。字面意义上的。什么书？你写的吗？我能看一整天。哦，那是他们只是让我们继续用角色的身份交谈的时候。是的。这有点像一个长篇即兴表演练习。是的。好吧，当仓库里发生这一切的时候，帕姆、瑞安和迈克尔就像最好的朋友一样。他们在迈克尔的办公室里，为迈克尔制作的照片拼贴画咯咯地笑。我的意思是，瑞安和帕姆在迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司时互相痛恨，现在他们简直就像，就像老战友一样。我太喜欢了。我喜欢这种动态。我们有一个
fan question from Adrian M on the memory board that Michael makes, when were the photos taken? Was it done while you were filming the Michael Scott Paper Company episodes? Yes, Adrian, they were. We knew ahead of time that we were going to need these photos because Randy Cordray, he would get the scripts early so that he could anticipate sight gags and props and locations and all these things that go into planning an episode. So he knew that for this episode we would need these pictures. So while we were filming broke, we took all these pictures for the collage. A storyline is about to start that I loved so much Jenna and it is Jim and Creed. I loved it so much. I loved how like Creed is being so normal that it's makes you more suspicious
来自阿德里安·M的粉丝提问，关于迈克尔制作的记忆板，照片是什么时候拍的？是在你们拍摄迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司剧集时拍的吗？是的，阿德里安，是的。我们提前知道我们需要这些照片，因为兰迪·科德雷会提前拿到剧本，以便他能预见视觉笑话、道具、地点以及筹备一集所需的所有这些事情。所以他知道这一集我们需要这些照片。因此，在我们拍摄《破产》期间，我们为拼贴画拍了所有这些照片。一段我非常喜欢的故事情节即将开始，珍娜，那就是吉姆和克里德。我太喜欢了。我喜欢克里德表现得如此正常，以至于让你更加怀疑他。
of him. I loved just whenever Jim and Creed were in scenes together and as you know, John Krasinski was always just like completely disintegrating into laughter. Well, John loved doing scenes with Creed. So I called Creed because I was like, Creed, you have this hilarious storyline with Jim in this episode and I sort of reminded him of it. I had the shooting draft and we went through it together, Jenna. I know. And one of the things that cracked us up, it was a line that Creed loved and it didn't make it in. I want to share it with you. So the scene starts that Creed is in the corner and in the shooting draft, Jim gets a soda and Creed says, you're going to be happy with that.
关于他。我太喜欢吉姆和克里德一起出现的场景了，而且如你所知，约翰·卡拉辛斯基总是会笑得前仰后合。嗯，约翰很喜欢和克里德演对手戏。所以我给克里德打电话，我说：“克里德，这集里你和吉姆有一条超级搞笑的故事线。”我稍微提醒了他一下。我手里有拍摄剧本，我们一起过了一遍，珍娜。我懂。其中一个让我们笑喷的桥段是克里德很喜欢的一句台词，但最后被剪掉了。我想和你们分享一下。场景一开始，克里德在角落里，在拍摄剧本中，吉姆拿了一罐苏打水，克里德说：“你会对那个感到高兴的。”
And Jim says, hi. And then Creed says, I come here to take a break. And Jim says, yeah, here's the line that got cut. Creed says, the restroom. That's what I call it. Creed calls the break room, the restroom. And then the rest is scripted. Let's talk about this storyline because eventually Creed is going to suggest that they play a game. Yes. And that game is going to be chess. And not only that, Creed is a very good chess player. Yeah. Well, I texted with John Krasinski about this because I wanted to know, is John a good chess player? Because I knew you were reaching out to Creed. So I was like, I'll get John's side of this. John said he knows how to play chess, but very poorly.
吉姆说：“嗨。”然后克里德说：“我来这儿是为了休息一下。”吉姆说：“行吧。”被剪掉的台词是这样的。克里德说：“洗手间。我是这么叫它的。”克里德把休息室叫作洗手间。然后剩下的就是剧本里有的了。我们来聊聊这条故事线，因为最终克里德会提议他们玩个游戏。是的。而那个游戏就是下国际象棋。不仅如此，克里德还是个非常出色的国际象棋棋手。是的。嗯，我为此给约翰·卡拉辛斯基发了短信，因为我想知道，约翰是个好棋手吗？因为我知道你联系了克里德。所以我想，我来听听约翰的说法。约翰说他会下国际象棋，但下得很烂。
Well, this is what Creed said. Creed said, yes, I can play chess. I'm not an aficionado, but I have basic skills. And he said he's actually looking forward to playing chess with his granddaughters. Oh, he wants to share it with them. Oh, you know what? Lee's dad plays chess with my son. And it warms my heart every time I look over and see them playing chess. It's like his thing he does with his grandpa. Yeah. And then what's so fantastic is this chess runner ends with Jim's talking head that says, I'm just hiding out until all this stuff blows over with Creed playing chess at work. He's winning. I feel like I'm describing a dream I had. Yeah, exactly. So listen, when the gang comes back from down in the warehouse, Michael, Pam,
嗯，克里德是这么说的。克里德说：“是的，我会下国际象棋。我不是狂热爱好者，但我有基本功。”他还说他其实很期待和他的孙女们下棋。哦，他想和她们分享。哦，你知道吗？李的爸爸和我儿子下棋。每当我转头看到他们下棋，心里就暖洋洋的。这就像是他和他爷爷一起做的事。是的。然后最棒的是，这段下棋的插曲以吉姆的采访镜头结束，吉姆说：“我只是在躲着，直到所有这些事情平息下来。”伴随着克里德在工作时下国际象棋。他赢了。我觉得我像是在描述我做的一个梦。没错，完全是。所以听着，当大家从仓库回来时，迈克尔、帕姆，
and Ryan are like, where have you been? And they claim that they've been at lunch. And we're like, it's very early in the morning. What all did you have for lunch? Because they're trying to trap them. Andy very quickly shares this. I had a salmon salad with water, no ice. I was going to get a soda, but the waiter talked me out of it. Her name was Flo. She had black hair. And immediately, this is like the art of lying. Okay, like he thinks by sharing a ton of details, right, that that's going to make them seem normal. But let me tell you, whenever someone gives me an answer like this, I'm like, suspect. Yeah, you want to have the detail, but you don't just lay it all out at the top in one big blob. No. Michael, Pam, and Ryan are like, oh, well,
还有瑞安都问：“你们去哪儿了？”他们声称他们去吃午饭了。而我们则觉得：现在是大清早啊。你们午饭都吃了些什么？因为他们正试图设套抓住他们。安迪很快就说出了这些。我吃了一份三文鱼沙拉配水，不加冰。我本来想点苏打水，但服务员劝我别点。她叫弗洛。她有一头黑发。马上，这就好比是撒谎的艺术。好吧，就好像他认为通过分享一大堆细节，这能让他们显得很自然。但我要告诉你，每当有人给我这样的回答时，我都会想：可疑。是的，你想提供细节，但你不能一开始就把它们全盘托出，堆成一大坨。不。迈克尔、帕姆和瑞安就觉得，哦，好吧，
if you guys, you know, went out to lunch, then I guess we can eat what's in the fridge here. Yes. And then the three of us go in the fridge and we start eating everybody's lunches. Please watch this in the bloopers, you guys. Well, I remember it. Steve took a huge bite out of a cold salmon fillet. You're shoveling potato salad in your mouth. It was an egg salad lady. Oh my God. And people asked, was it really egg salad? It was like it was making us laugh. You laugh so hard with a mouthful of egg salad that like, there was like egg salad spittle. It was so gross. Oh my God. I remember it like it was yesterday. Well, we got a fan catch from Nikki S. about all this food. She says, when Michael is taking the
如果你们，你知道，出去吃午饭了，那我猜我们可以吃冰箱里的东西了。是的。然后我们三个走进冰箱，开始吃大家的午饭。请大家一定要去看看幕后花絮。嗯，我记得。史蒂夫狠狠咬了一大口冷三文鱼片。你把土豆沙拉大口大口塞进嘴里。那是蛋黄酱沙拉，女士。哦天哪。人们问，那真的是蛋黄酱沙拉吗？当时把我们都逗笑了。你嘴里塞满了蛋黄酱沙拉，笑得太厉害了，以至于里面都有蛋黄酱的唾沫星子。太恶心了。哦天哪。我记得就像发生在昨天一样。嗯，我们收到了尼基·S.发来的一条关于所有这些食物的粉丝来信。她说，当迈克尔把
sales staff's lunches out of the fridge, he takes a green wrapped sandwich and it's from a gas station chain called Sheets. They are known for their food commonly called MTO, which stands for made to order. So I looked it up and there is this string of gas stations called Sheets in the area and they make made to order food. Here's their commercial. I am starving. I'll stop at Sheets. I can't get good food at a gas station. Really? You couldn't have just agreed. See, so in this moment they've turned into donkeys. You know what that does to you and me. I'm sorry. Yep. It makes an ass of you and me. See? Don't assume you can't get fresh made to order food at a gas station. Sheets,
销售人员的午餐从冰箱里拿出来时，他拿了一个绿色包装的三明治，它是从一家名为希茨（Sheetz）的加油站连锁店买的。它们以食物闻名，通常被称为MTO，也就是“按需定制”（made to order）的意思。所以我查了一下，这个地区确实有一家名为希茨的加油站，他们制作按需定制的食物。这是他们的广告。我快饿死了。我要在希茨停一下。我才不在加油站买好吃的呢。真的吗？你就不能同意一下吗？你看，在这个时刻，他们变成了蠢驴。你知道这会对你和我产生什么影响。抱歉。没错。这会让你和我变成大笨蛋。看到了吗？别以为你在加油站买不到新鲜的现做食物。希茨，
be over love. Yeah. Ding dong ding dong ding. So here's what is that ad? What is happening in that ad? It's two people driving in a car and they want some food and as soon as he assumes that you can't get made to order food at a gas station, they turn into asses and they start he-hawing. But here's the thing that got me that I was thinking. Do you remember in the injury when Michael wants some yams? Yeah. Ryan says you can't get yams at a gas station? Yeah. I just wondered does Sheets sell yams? Can I get a yam on my sandwich? I looked at their menus. It seems like each location sometimes has slightly different items. I could not find one that had yams. So I guess Ryan is still right. But Sheets, I think you should consider, I don't know, for all
爱不释手。耶。咚咚咚咚。所以，那是什广告？那个广告里在演什么？是两个人开车出行，他们想吃点东西，一当他认为你在加油站买不到现做食物时，他们就变成了蠢驴，开始发出驴叫声。但让我琢磨的是这样一件事。你还记得在《受伤》那一集里，迈克尔想要吃山药吗？记得。瑞安说你在加油站买不到山药？对。我只是在想，希茨卖山药吗？我能在我的三明治里加山药吗？我看过他们的菜单。似乎每个分店有时都有略微不同的商品。我找不到一家有卖山药的。所以我想瑞安还是对的。但是希茨，我觉得你们应该考虑一下，我不知道，为了所有的
the office fans out there. If you started selling yams at your gas station, it might be a hit. Maybe it's a holiday item. Yeah, it's a holiday item. I have a question for Sheets. Is that bread for real? Because that bread was like the size of a Buick. I don't know. It's seriously that bread was the size of Steve's head. Here's an interesting tidbit that Brent shared in the DVD commentary. This entire third act was written in a breakout pod of writers of Mindy, BJ, Gene and Lee, in about 12 hours. Wow. Entire third act. I remember Brent sharing with us and Alicia supports this, that this whole script came down to the wire. That like, this is the end of the season, they're backed up, they're running out of time. We're on fumes. We are. Randy noted that this
办公室粉丝。如果你们开始在加油站卖山药，可能会大受欢迎。也许这是个节日限定商品。对，是个节日限定商品。我有个问题要问希茨。那面包是真的吗？因为那面包有别克汽车那么大。我不知道。说真的，那面包有史蒂夫的头那么大。这里有个有趣的八卦，布伦特在DVD评论音轨里分享过。整个第三幕是由明迪、BJ、吉恩和李组成的编剧小组在大约12小时内写出来的。哇。整个第三幕。我记得布伦特跟我们分享过，艾莉西亚也证实了这一点，整个剧本是卡着最后期限完成的。就像是，这是季末，他们积压了工作，时间不够用了。我们在靠最后一点精力硬撑。确实。兰迪指出，这
whole episode takes place just at Dunder Mifflin and that the production had requested that because they were getting ready for our big 100th episode season finale company Picnic. They were prepping and he said, we just couldn't afford to be going on location. We needed an episode that happened right on our set. So maybe that contributed too to some of these rewrites at the end. I also want to give a shout out to our unsung hero a little bit, Phil Shea, who every week had to do so much. If you go to deleted scenes, there's a scene where Jim is welcoming Pam to the despot of Jim and Dwight and Pam now and he gives her this little island and on the island it's Jim and Pam and Dwight. Okay. Okay. It's like a little figurine. Why do I not have this item?
整集都只在邓德米夫林发生，制片方提出这个要求是因为他们正在为我们盛大的第一百集季终集“公司野餐”做准备。他们当时在筹备，他说，我们实在负担不起外景拍摄。我们需要一集直接在我们的片场就能完成的故事。所以也许这也促成了最后的一些剧本重写。我还想向我们的幕后英雄菲尔·谢伊表达敬意，他每周都有做不完的工作。如果你去看删减片段，有一个场景是吉姆欢迎帕姆来到吉姆和德怀特的专制统治下，现在的帕姆和吉姆、德怀特在一起，他给了她这个小岛，岛上有吉姆、帕姆和德怀特。好吧。好吧。就像一个小雕像。为什么我没有这个东西？
You should own this item. In the script, it was supposed to be Jim, Pam, and Dwight and deleted scenes. It's sort of like a makeshift of that. But I guess Phil Shea spent tons of time getting this thing made. Of course. And it didn't even make it in. Yeah. Well, now we're coming up to a scene that is very famous as well, perhaps as famous as our chilly cold open. For sure. I mean, I've seen people do this scene as a Halloween costume. So many people. It's the scene where Toby has to confront Meredith about her casual outfit, saying that it's a bit revealing. So when she tugs on her skirt, it flashes her top when she pulls it back up, then it flashes the bottom. It's a lot. It has two standout famous lines that are quoted quite a bit to Kate Flannery.
你应该拥有这个东西。在剧本里，这本该是吉姆、帕姆和德怀特，但在删减片段里。它有点像那个的临时替代品。但我想菲尔·谢伊花了很多时间才把这东西做出来。当然。而且它甚至都没剪进去。嗯，现在我们要迎来一个也非常著名的场景，也许和我们的“辣椒冷开场”一样著名。肯定的。我的意思是，我见过有人把这个场景当成万圣节服装。好多人。就是托比不得不就梅雷迪思的休闲装质问她，说这有点暴露。所以当她扯裙子时，上衣会闪光，当她把它拉回去时，底部又会闪光。内容很多。里面有两句非常经典的台词，经常被引用来对凯特·弗兰纳里说。大声点。
Meredith, your boob is out. And dammit, Meredith, where are your panties? Well, when we talked to Brent Forrester about this episode, he told us this. He said, when he joined the writing staff of the office in season three, he noticed that the writers were sometimes having a hard time writing for the character of Meredith, who he personally loved. And he said, everyone knew Kate Flannery was really funny, but they just hadn't cracked the code of this character. Brent shared that one day he was at lunch and he happened to be sitting next to Kate. And so he just asked her, Kate, what makes you funny? And apparently Kate said something to the effect of Brent, I'm the daughter of an old Irish bar owner. My comfort zone is loud and filthy.
梅雷迪思，你的胸部露出来了。还有，该死的，梅雷迪思，你的内裤呢？嗯，当我们和布伦特·福雷斯特谈论这一集时，他告诉了我们这件事。他说，当他在第三季加入《办公室》的编剧团队时，他注意到编剧们有时很难为梅雷迪思这个角色进行创作，而他本人非常喜欢这个角色。他说，大家都知道凯特·弗兰纳里真的很有趣，但他们就是没能破解这个角色的密码。布伦特分享说，有一天他吃午饭时，正好坐在凯特旁边。于是他直接问她：“凯特，是什么让你觉得好笑？”显然凯特说的大意是：“布伦特，我是个老爱尔兰酒吧老板的女儿。我的舒适区就是喧闹和粗俗。”
So he went back to the writers and he told them this and he said it revolutionized the writing for Meredith. He got credited with cracking the code. And he was like, all I did was just ask the actress. He said it was actually a good lesson. Like, go ask the actress. Like, what are you really good at? What do you like to do? Right. What's your thing? And then the writer's room can lean into that. And you mentioned this to Kate, right? I did. I was talking to Kate on the phone this week. And I said, Kate, we are coming up on casual Friday. Also, you guys, when we're recording this, Halloween has just happened. Kate is constantly tagged in photos of people dressed as Meredith in this purple dress. Yes. With sort of a pixelated boob. Yes. You know.
于是他回到编剧室把这事告诉了大家，并说这彻底革新了梅雷迪思的剧本创作。他被认为破解了这个密码。而他说：“我所做的只是去问了这位女演员。”他说这其实是个很好的教训。就像，去问问女演员。比如，你到底擅长什么？你喜欢做什么？对吧。你的绝活是什么？然后编剧室就可以顺着这个方向创作。你把这事告诉凯特了吧？我说了。这周我跟凯特通了电话。我说：“凯特，我们要迎来‘休闲星期五’了。”另外，大家伙儿，当我们录制这一期时，万圣节刚过去。凯特经常在人们扮成穿这件紫色裙子的梅雷迪思的照片中被@。是的。胸部带有马赛克的那种。是的。你知道的。
I've seen them. Yeah. So I asked Kate about this scene. And here's what she had to share. Hey, Office Lady podcast fans. I have to tell you, when we did the table read, I knew exactly how well this was going to pull. It was so well written. The scene where Toby tells Meredith to pull up her dress. It was just brilliantly written and kind of like jumping out of an airplane whenever I'm topless or more. Yeah. Because you just got to do it. You can't even judge it. You just got to go. And luckily, Paul is a great, he's a great partner in a scene because he plays it very small and real. So it reminds me to keep it small and real. And not always easy for me. But yeah, it's so much fun. And there was talk of a merkin at one point. A merkin is a wig
我都见过。嗯。所以我问了凯特关于这个场景的事。以下是她的分享：“嘿，办公室女士播客的粉丝们。我必须告诉你们，当我们进行围读剧本时，我就清楚地知道这会带来多好的反响。它写得太好了。托比让梅雷迪思把裙子往上拉的那个场景。简直写得绝妙，而且只要我裸着上身或者穿得更少，就有点像从飞机上跳伞一样。”是的。因为你只能豁出去。你甚至不能去评判它。你只能上。幸运的是，保罗是个很好的，他在场景里是个很好的搭档，因为他演得很克制、很真实。所以这提醒了我，要保持克制和真实。对我来说这并不总是那么容易。但是，是的，太好玩了。而且当时还讨论过用“人工阴毛假发”。人工阴毛假发就是假发，
for down there. Yeah. Luckily, the pixelation at NBC. And also credit must be given to Alicia for creating this amazing dress that was so easy to hike up or hike down and have a problem. So yeah, great wardrobe malfunction dress from a great wardrobe designer, Alicia. So thank you for that. And it's one of the few things I wish I'd kept and I did not. I do have a longer version. Someday I'll wear it in public. Yeah, but well, I'll to save the date, you guys hold your breath. Okay, here we go. Thank you. Have a great day. And I hope it's casual day. Okay. Did you notice that her dress was also purple? I did notice that. I talked to Alicia about this dress. It was actually a bubble skirt. Yeah, it was not actually meant to be a dress.
用在下面的那种。是的。幸运的是，NBC进行了马赛克处理。而且还要感谢艾莉西亚创造了这条神奇的裙子，它非常容易提起来或放下去，而且不会出问题。所以，是的，这是一件来自伟大服装设计师艾莉西亚的、绝佳的服装故障裙。所以非常感谢。这是我少数希望自己能留下来却没有留下的东西之一。我确实有一个更长的版本。总有一天我要在公众场合穿它。好吧，好吧，大家留出日期，屏住呼吸。好吧，我们开始吧。谢谢。祝你们有美好的一天。希望今天是休闲日。好吧。你注意到她的裙子也是紫色的吗？我确实注意到了。我跟艾莉西亚聊过这条裙子。其实这是一条泡泡裙。是的，它本来不是当裙子设计的。
It's meant to be worn at the waist. Yeah. I love that Kate brought up the merkin. That is like a word I forgot I even knew. Same. Oh my gosh, a merkin is like the fake. It's fake hair down there. Fake hair down there. Oh my gosh. You know, Kate and I went on to talk on the phone about this. And she shared with me that doing these nude scenes, they were definitely not in her comfort zone, you know? And every time she did them, she had to really step out of her comfort zone, but she would just go for it. She told me she was like, Angie, I never really got used to doing these. You know, I've had to do scenes in movies where I'm wearing very little or a love scene or whatever. And it always feels awkward to me too. Yeah. Well, I also asked Kate,
它是设计来戴在腰上的。是的。我很高兴凯特提到了假阴毛。那真是一个我以为自己都忘光了的词。一样。哦天哪，假阴毛就像是假的。那是下面的假发。下面戴的假发。哦天哪。你知道，凯特和我接着在电话里聊了这件事。她跟我分享说，拍这些裸戏，绝对不在她的舒适区里，你知道吗？每次她拍这些戏时，她都必须真正走出自己的舒适区，但她就是会豁出去。她告诉我：“安吉，我从来没有真正习惯过拍这些。你知道，我得在电影里拍一些穿得很少的戏，或者亲密戏什么的。对我来说，那感觉总是很尴尬。”是的。嗯，我还问了凯特，
what was she wearing underneath this purple dress? Oh, we got a lot of fan questions about that. What was it? She said she was wearing a flesh toned mole skin. Yeah. You know, I used to use that when I did ballet to wrap my toes. Yeah. You know, guys, it's like that sort of like a fuzzy felt thing that sticks to your skin. Exactly. In fact, they've made it for blisters, but they use it to cover your boob area. And then the other thing she was wearing was a thong. Well, we spoke to Randy Cordray about this a little bit, and he said that he did insist on a close set. And what that means is that normally when you're doing scenes, those scenes are broadcast backstage for the hair and makeup people to observe, to make sure everything's okay, different crew members,
她在这条紫色裙子里面穿了什么？哦，我们收到了很多关于这个的粉丝提问。是什么？她说她穿了一件肉色的贴身鼹鼠皮胶布。是的。你知道的，我跳芭蕾舞时过去常用那个来裹脚趾。是的。你知道的，伙计们，那就像那种会粘在你皮肤上的毛茸茸的毛毡东西。没错。事实上，它们是为水泡制作的，但他们用它来遮住胸部区域。然后她穿的另一件东西是丁字裤。嗯，我们跟兰迪·科德雷稍微聊了一下这件事，他说他确实坚持要进行“封闭式拍摄”。这意味着什么呢？也就是说，通常当你拍摄场景时，这些场景会在后台进行直播，供发型和化妆人员观看，以确保一切正常，不同的剧组人员，
anyone backstage can sort of see on a live feed what is happening on the set. Those get shut off when you ever have a scene like this. No monitors backstage. And then similarly, no guests are allowed on those days, and no photography, of course, and only the people who need to be in the scene or on the set are allowed on the set. That's right. If you're not part of the scene, you're not there. Exactly. The next scene made me laugh because Ryan is building a complaint, but it's Dwight's former client. Dwight has had this client for 10 years who's never had a complaint, and now this client wants to leave. Did you catch the client's name? No. They say it over and over. I don't know why it just tickled me because I never noticed it before. Because you and I are
后台的任何人都可以通过实时画面看到片场正在发生的事情。每当有这样的场景时，这些画面就会被切断。后台没有监视器。同样地，那些天不允许有访客，当然也不能拍照，而且只有那些必须在场景中或片场的人才被允许进入片场。没错。如果你不是场景的一部分，你就不能在那里。没错。接下来的场景把我逗笑了，因为瑞安在提意见，但这是德怀特的老客户。德怀特这个客户跟了10年从来没抱怨过，现在这个客户想解约。你注意到那个客户的名字了吗？没有。他们一遍又遍地念。我不知道为什么它就是把我逗乐了，因为我以前从没注意到。因为你和我
truly rewatching this. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Mr. Bart. Mr. Bart. Mr. Bart. They're very sad about losing Mr. Bart, but it builds to this crescendo where Phyllis ends up tearfully saying to Michael, you know, Michael, you thought you were attacking corporate, but we were the ones who got hurt. You should be apologizing to us. And she says, Michael, you always said we were a family, and then you went after us. Well, they talked in the DVD commentary about this moment, that it was a very pivotal story moment because it had to flip Michael. Yes. So they needed Phyllis to really perform in this moment. It all came down to her. And on the commentary, there was a little bit of a debate between Brent and Mindy. Mindy was like, was Phyllis being calculating?
真的在重温这部剧。哦，是的。是的。巴特先生。巴特先生。巴特先生。他们对失去巴特先生感到非常难过，但这发展到了一个高潮，菲尔斯最终含泪对迈克尔说：“你知道，迈克尔，你以为你在攻击公司，但受伤的是我们。你应该向我们道歉。”她说：“迈克尔，你总是说我们是一个大家庭，然后你却把矛头指向了我们。”嗯，他们在DVD评论音轨里谈到了这一刻，这是一个非常关键的故事转折点，因为它必须让迈克尔转变态度。是的。所以他们需要菲尔斯在这个时刻真正发挥出色。一切都归结于她。在评论音轨中，布伦特和明迪之间产生了一点争论。明迪觉得：菲尔斯是在算计吗？
Right. Was she manipulating Michael? Right. And then Claire Scanlon, who was also in the DVD commentary, was like, no, I think she was being sincere. I read it as sincere. I think she played it sincere. I thought Phyllis performed it as sincere. The thing that surprised me about this whole scene was that Ryan even had a client. I know. That's so true. I don't know. I guess I thought maybe, maybe he has one. He has one, but that one's leaving. But I think big props to Phyllis because I think she really delivered in that moment. And you see how Michael reevaluates everything because he does see this office as his family. Dwight's going to write another letter in Invisible Ink and fan catch from Carla Jay who says, oh my gosh, can we please talk about
对。她是在操纵迈克尔吗？对。然后同样在DVD评论音轨里的克莱尔·斯坎伦就说：“不，我觉得她是真心的。我觉得她是真心的。我觉得她演得很真诚。”让我对整个场景感到惊讶的是，瑞安居然也有客户。我知道。确实如此。我不知道。我猜我想也许，也许他有一个。他有一个，但那个要走了。但我认为要向菲尔斯致以崇高的敬意，因为我觉得她在那一刻真的表现得很出色。你可以看到迈克尔是如何重新评估一切的，因为他确实把这个办公室看作是他的家庭。德怀特要用隐形墨水写另一封信，还有来自卡拉·J的粉丝来信，她说：“哦天哪，我们能聊聊
how Dwight is using Ryan's cup from Kelly's America's Cut Talent Party to paint the secret urine messages onto the memos. I noticed that as well. I thought it was very funny. Clearly, Dwight has peed in that cup. Listen, in the end, Michael is going to apologize to the sales force and he's going to agree to give them their clients back. But this means he's going to have to fire, reassign one of his Michael Scott paper company employees. Yeah, he can only keep one of them on as a salesperson and he's going to have to decide if it's Pam or Ryan. Jim is going to try to help Michael by telling him maybe he should make a list of pros and cons about each person. That doesn't go very far because Michael tries to get Jim
德怀特是怎么用凯莉的‘美国才华横溢’派对上的瑞安的杯子，把秘密尿液留言画在备忘录上的吗？”我也注意到了这一点。我觉得这非常搞笑。很显然，德怀特在那个杯子里尿过尿。听着，最后，迈克尔要向销售团队道歉，并同意把他们的客户还给他们。但这意味着他必须解雇、重新调配他的一位迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司的员工。是的，他只能留下一名销售人员，他必须决定是留帕姆还是瑞安。吉姆试图通过建议他也许可以为每个人列一张优缺点清单来帮助迈克尔。这并没有什么用，因为迈克尔试图让吉姆
to say some cons about Pam. And I guess what they settle on is that I have a shrill voice. Sometimes when those moments wind up in a script, I'm like, hmm, does someone in the writer's room find my voice awful? Oh, 100%. Only sometimes they said, only sometimes her voice is shrill. I guarantee you, someone was like, well, what could we say? I don't know. Maybe her voice gets grating. Right? Yeah. Sorry, all you podcast listeners. I had an audition one time for a national campaign for bananas. Go on. Yeah. You had to eat a banana in the audition. And I didn't get the part. The casting director, as I was delivering my lines, she said, I'm sorry, I'm going to stop you. Can you lower your register? And I said, oh, okay.
说出帕姆的一些缺点。我想他们最后达成的一点是，我的声音很刺耳。有时当这些桥段出现在剧本里时，我就会想，嗯，编剧室里有人觉得我的声音很难听吗？哦，百分之百。他们只是有时说，只是有时她的声音很刺耳。我向你保证，有人当时就在想，嗯，我们能说点什么？我不知道。也许她的声音听起来很烦人？对吧？是的。对不起了，所有的播客听众。我曾经为一场国家级的香蕉广告试镜过。接着说。是的。你得在试镜时吃一根香蕉。然后我没被录用。选角导演在我念台词时说：“对不起，我要打断你。你能降低你的音域吗？”我说：“哦，好的。”
So I have to take a bite of the banana and then say the line, whatever the line is, these bananas are great, whatever it was, I can't remember. But so I went, I guess I was going like, these bananas are great or something. And so then I took a bite of the banana and you guys take a bite of banana and then try to say a line. Then I'm like, these bananas are great. I didn't get it. But for the rest of my career, I thought, oh my gosh, is my voice shrill and grating? And I asked my agent when I didn't get it. I was like, was it because she wanted me to lower my register? Did she say something about my register? And my agent said, no, she actually said, they thought the way you ate the banana was awkward. Oh my gosh. How do actors make it? How do you come back from that?
所以我必须咬一口香蕉，然后念台词，不管台词是什么，这些香蕉很好吃，诸如此类的，我记不清了。但所以我去了，我想我当时大概是这样的：“这些香蕉很好吃”或者别的什么。于是我咬了一口香蕉，然后你们大家咬一口香蕉，再试着念一句台词。然后我就像：“这些香蕉很好吃。”我没被选上。但在我职业生涯的剩余时间里，我都在想：“哦天哪，我的声音真的很刺耳很烦人吗？”当落选时我问了我的经纪人。我问：“是因为她想让我降低音域吗？她对我的音域说什么了吗？”我的经纪人说：“没有，她实际上说的是，他们觉得你吃香蕉的方式很尴尬。”哦天哪。演员们是怎么挺过来的？你怎么能从那样的打击中恢复过来？
I don't know. How does that not give you a complex? I don't know. In two areas, your voice and your banana eating. I know. That was always such a tricky thing. You'd go to an audition and then you wouldn't get it and you would just want to know anything. You would say, was there any feedback? Any feedback, desperate for feedback. Oh my gosh. So you could do it better next time, so you could learn. And then you find out you sound like a banshee and you eat a banana like a f***ing idiot. Exactly. And then when are you going to use that information? What's your next banana eating role that you can apply that to? I will never eat a banana on camera. Let me tell you. All right. Can we talk about this scene where everyone is ganging up on Toby
我不知道。那怎么能不让你有心理阴影呢？我不知道。在两个方面：你的声音和你吃香蕉的方式。我知道。那总是件很棘手的事。你去参加试镜，然后没被录用，你就会想要知道任何反馈。你会说，有什么反馈吗？任何反馈，极度渴望反馈。哦天哪。这样你下次就能做得更好，就能吸取教训。然后你发现自己听起来像个报丧女妖，吃香蕉的德行就像个白痴。没错。然后你什么时候才能用到这些信息呢？你接下来的哪个吃香蕉角色能用得上这个？我再也不会在镜头前吃香蕉了。我这么跟你说吧。好了。我们能聊聊这个场景吗？大家都在围攻托比
about casual Friday because it's delightful? All right. When you guys watch it, when Toby says it's canceled, everyone is like boo in Angela, full smile jumping up and down. So happy. But Dwight starts to take over this meeting and he says that you could still have casual Friday, but he's going to give a few rules like earth tones only. And did you hear this one at 18 minutes, 13 seconds? Women are forbidden to wear pants. Who has Dwight been talking to? An executive at NBC perhaps. I wonder where that one came from. I'll tell you what's going to happen, boys. Once they start wearing pants, they're going to want things like, you know, equal rights. I don't know. Which by the way, I'm sorry, soapbox moment. Can you believe that there is still not a ratified
关于休闲星期五的事，因为这太逗了。好吧。当你们看的时候，当托比说取消时，每个人都在嘘，安吉丽娜则满脸笑容地跳上跳下。超级开心。但德怀特开始接管这个会议，他说你还是可以有休闲星期五，但他要定一些规则，比如只能穿大地色系。你听到18分13秒的那句话了吗？禁止女性穿裤子。德怀特到底在跟谁说话？也许是NBC的高管吧。我不知道那句话是从哪儿来的。我告诉你们会发生什么，伙计们。一旦她们开始穿裤子，她们就会想要一些东西，比如，你知道的，平等的权利。我不知道。顺便说一句，抱歉，我要发表一下慷慨激昂的言论了。你们能相信到现在还没有批准
equal rights amendment? That in our constitution, the fabric of our nation, women are still not seen as equal legally. What the F is that? Now, the states have finally, there's enough that have ratified this amendment, but I guess they did it a little bit too late. They missed the deadline because it took like how many years over 20, 25 years, 30 years. So anyway, I guess they're trying to fix that loophole and say that we should ratify this amendment already. I say about time and women can wear whatever they want on the bottom and we can show our panty lines and we could have pockets and we can have equal rights under the law. Thank you. Call your representatives. Ask for all of them. They'll be confused by the pockets and panty lines, but just doesn't matter.
《平等权利修正案》吗？在我们的宪法中，在我们国家的基石里，女性在法律上仍然不被视为是平等的。这到底是什么鬼？现在，各州终于有足够数量的州批准了这个修正案，但我想他们做得有点太晚了。他们错过了截止日期，因为这花了大概多少年，超过20年、25年、30年。所以不管怎样，我想他们正在试图修复那个漏洞，并表示我们应该已经批准这个修正案了。我认为是时候了，女性可以在下半身穿任何她们想穿的衣服，我们可以露出内裤痕，我们可以有口袋，我们可以在法律面前拥有平等的权利。谢谢。给你的议员打电话。要求所有人这么做。他们会对口袋和内裤痕感到困惑，但没关系。
Okay, clearly we're going to Washington. Could you imagine me in Washington testifying before Congress? I would love it. I would love it. I would want you to wear the biggest baggiest pants. I would have pockets from my waist down to my ebbing ankles. When one of the old men that's on Congress asked you a question, I would want you to stand up in your pants and say one second and you pull a full laptop out of one of your pockets. And you know what, here's the thing. In the back, they fit really tight so you can see my panty line and it's going to be the harshest panty line you've ever seen. Your target laundry day undies. A hundred percent. And then I'm going to say ratify that amendment already. And then when it's ratified, you're
好吧，很明显我们要去华盛顿。你能想象我在华盛顿国会前作证吗？我会乐意的。我会非常愿意。我会希望你穿着最大、最宽松的裤子。我希望从我的腰部一直到我纤细的脚踝都有口袋。当国会里的某个老头问你问题时，我希望你穿着裤子站起来说“等一下”，然后从口袋里掏出一整台笔记本电脑。你知道吗，重点是：后面要勒得很紧，这样就能看到我的内裤痕迹，这将是你见过最明显的内裤痕迹。你专门留到洗衣服那天穿的内裤。百分之百。然后我要说：“快批准那个修正案吧。”等到批准了，你
going to say, see, you gave us pants and we took over your fear about us in pants. It came true. That's right. All right. All right. Michael is going to call Pam into his office and we are going to find out who got the sales job. Was it Pam? Was it Ryan? Michael, he's got to prank you first. This man loves a fake fire and a fake hire. He loves it. What is that about him? He tells Pam he's really sorry, but he gave Ryan the sales job. Yeah. And Pam is disappointed. And then he starts to giggle. Yeah. He's joking. And she's like, Michael. Yeah. He offered Ryan his temp job back and Pam is going to get this sales position. She's so happy about it. She is. As she's leaving
就会说：“看吧，你们给了我们裤子，而我们顺理成章地利用了你们对我们穿裤子的恐惧。成真了。”没错。好了。好了。迈克尔要把帕姆叫进办公室，我们要看看是谁得到了销售工作。是帕姆吗？是瑞恩吗？迈克尔，他得先整你一下。这个人太喜欢假火灾和假录用了。他太喜欢了。他这人是怎么回事？他告诉帕姆他真的很遗憾，但他把销售工作给了瑞恩。是的。而帕姆很失望。然后他开始咯咯笑。是的。他在开玩笑。帕姆就说：“迈克尔。”是的。他把临时工的工作还给了瑞恩，而帕姆将得到销售职位。她太高兴了。确实如此。当她离开
the office, Michael says, send Aaron in. Oh no. So you know he's about to do some prank on Aaron. Aaron, I want you guys to know that that is where the scene ended. In the shooting draft, he says, send Aaron in. There's no more dialogue. Oh yes. Brent told us this. Brent said that this scene coming up was Ellie Kemper's first one-on-one scene with Steve Carell. But it wasn't even supposed to happen. It was all improv. That is amazing. So basically, they just let the cameras keep rolling. He says, send Aaron in. Aaron walks in and then Steve and Aaron do this little improvised scene. And they loved it and it made it into the episode. That is amazing. That closes out casual Friday. I loved this episode. I loved this podcast.
办公室时，迈克尔说：“让艾伦进来。”哦不。所以你知道他马上要对艾伦搞什么恶作剧了。艾伦，我想让你们知道，场景就是在这里结束的。在拍摄剧本里，他说的是“让艾伦进来”。没有更多的台词了。哦是的。布伦特告诉过我们这一点。布伦特说，接下来这个场景是艾莉·坎珀与史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的第一次对手戏。但这甚至都不是原本计划好的。全都是即兴发挥。太惊人了。所以基本上，他们只是让摄影机继续拍摄。他说“让艾伦进来”，艾伦走进来，然后史蒂夫和艾伦就进行了这段即兴表演。他们很喜欢，最后播出了。太惊人了。这就是“随性星期五”的结局。我太喜欢这一集了。我太喜欢这个播客了。
I loved, loved this episode so much too. And we have some shout outs and some thank yous. We really do. Thank you, Brian Baumgartner, for being our guest. Everyone, remember to check out his book, Welcome to Dunder Mifflin and his new podcast coming out next year. Off the beat. We need to thank Randy Cordray, Alicia Raycraft, Kate Flannery, Creed Bratton, John Krasinski. Thank you for letting us hit you up all the time for your scoop on these episodes. Seriously, God bless you guys because as we share a lot with you all listening, we text these guys and call them all the time. I know. I'm like, hey, John, how's it going? Weird question. Are you a good chess player? Yeah. Hey, Credo, how's it going? Listen,
我也太喜欢、太喜欢这一集了。我们还有一些感谢和致谢环节。真的有。谢谢布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳作为我们的嘉宾。大家记得去看看他的书《欢迎来到邓德米夫林》以及他明年推出的新播客《Off the beat》。我们要感谢兰迪·科德雷、艾莉西亚·雷克拉夫、凯特·弗兰纳里、克里德·布拉顿、约翰·卡拉辛斯基。谢谢你们一直让我们打扰，询问你们关于这些剧集的内幕消息。说真的，上帝保佑你们，因为正如我们跟所有听众分享的那样，我们经常给这些人发短信和打电话。我知道。我就像是在说：“嘿，约翰，最近怎么样？有个奇怪的问题。你是个好的国际象棋棋手吗？是的。”“嘿，克里德，最近怎么样？听着，
I left some limes on your porch. Also, can you play chess? I know. Pete, there must be like, what is happening? And finally, thank you to Brent Forrester, our long time writer on the office who also directed this episode. Guys, you know, Brent teaches comedy writing classes that anyone can take and you can find him and those classes over at BrentForrester.com. We highly recommend. If you have a creative idea that you want to turn into a comedy show, this is a good place to start. Yes. And check out Kate and Creed. You guys, they both have some wonderful shows coming up. You can find them on Instagram at the Real Kate Plannery and at Creed Bratton. And we will see you next week. Bye. Thank you for
我在你门廊上留了一些酸橙。还有，你会下国际象棋吗？”我知道。皮特一定在想，这到底是怎么回事？最后，感谢布伦特·福雷斯特，我们《办公室》的长期编剧，他也执导了这一集。大家知道，布伦特开设了任何人都可以参加的喜剧写作课程，你可以在 BrentForrester.com 上找到他和这些课程。我们强烈推荐。如果你有一个想要拍成喜剧节目的创意，这是一个很好的起点。是的。还有去看看凯特和克里德。大家注意，他们俩都有一些精彩的节目即将推出。你可以在 Instagram 上找到他们，账号是 @RealKateFlannery 和 @Creed Bratton。我们下周见。再见。谢谢收听
listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Office Ladies。Office Ladies 由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔，制片人是卡西·杰金斯，音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，副制片人是艾恩斯利·布巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。要收听 Office Ladies 的无广告版本，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。在 Stitcher Premium 免费试用一个月，请使用优惠码 Office。这一集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。